you know
hello and welcome to our red dead stream
oh oh you take a sip of coffee ah yeah I
need to yeah you cut right to that
gameplay Jake my name is Jake
I'm here with Rob land we have been
playing this game for the past week
don't worry this is a spoiler free
stream we're not gonna do any story
stuff however if you want to go and
completely blind maybe this isn't the
best place to be but for those of you
who are interested we're just kind of
gonna goof around for a couple hours
here yeah we won't do any main story so
we got our whole map here I'm I'm on the
3rd chapter so what does that maybe
halfway through no I love hearing that
so yellow icons are like the main story
missions we're gonna avoid those so
here's like a bounty hunt I say we do
that first yeah cool and then if you
guys have any questions feel free to ask
them in the chat and we'll get to them
as long as they're spoiler free like
just things about mechanics Arthur or
whatever it may be
we'll be happy to answer those and I'll
be checking that as we go for sure so
first things first this is the the camp
your hub camp were you frequently
visiting yeah you can shave over there
if you shave why don't we just do that
let's let's get ready for our expedition
give them a it's gonna mustache going
though so I had a nice beard going but I
shaved so you and you were saying that
you can grow your beard out to like your
belly yeah beard oil get some beard oil
longer yeah is it bigger than The
Witcher 3 I don't know I'm just gonna do
a clean shave for an uh did we break
street date nope it's the reviews are up
to if you are curious and want to see
what score this game has been getting
grease my hair back and you got to look
your finest finger about to hunt some
outlaws knows because I got to do the
auto safe okay
so let's see the map we've kind of
already shown it let's let me want to
get my fit on all right well we'll show
the map soon stick around a bit
well we're I mean we're gonna have to be
there eventually so you'll see it
eventually this is this is my fit I've
been rockin I was messing around with
other outfits I actually haven't like so
this is pretty cool too you can like
customize outfits and put two on your
horse at any time you put up to five I
think oh really I am it was only two it
might depend on the saddle
you have but I have a ton of outfits on
my horse
nice yeah because you know similarly to
like Legend of Zelda breath a wild you
know you're gonna go in cold weather
you better have a nice warm coat yeah it
doesn't affect you as much as elder like
you won't slowly lose health but your
cores which are basically there
basically dictate how your health
recharges health and stamina those will
drain quicker and cold if you aren't
bundled up
same thing with same thing with the heat
like if you're wearing a nice winter
coat and you're in ninety degree weather
yeah Arthur's gonna have a tough time
and you can check whether by hitting up
on the d-pad I think up or down on the
d-pad maybe down on the d-pad and it'll
come up and it'll tell you where you are
what the temperature is time of day
right all that kind of stuff they want
you to change his shoes I should have
done this earlier
okay there we go the customization for
both clothes and weapons is extensive
yeah because you can also change the
material in color right of pretty much
everything you buy right so here yeah
you can put chaps on so here my boots
but and put those guys on well we can go
to a store and buy some more stuff I
have I have a good amount of money and
that the other thing around about this
game too is that you really really like
need money I mean obviously you do but
it's it's like something that you are
consistently worrying about because you
also use money to upgrade your camp and
like you know stuff ain't cheap
no and I've noticed like it's pretty
tough to make money if you don't play
the story like it can be a lot of
grinding if you just want to like make a
ton of money and buy stuff right so the
other thing too I'll just show this is
like you know you you you talk to people
people are always having conversations
so you can greet and root agonize and I
would never ever antagonize sweet little
Jack here no he's so nice this is my
this is my horse you can pet your horse
so you have bonding right up to level 4
do you want to buy that yeah so you as
you spend time with your horse the the
your bond increases and as your bond
increase I think there's four levels and
you unlock new little skills for your
horses so for instance if you hit r1 I
believe your horse will do like a little
skid oh yeah look at that
it's pretty cool like it sounds cheesy
like I remember when like hearing about
I'd be like that sounds like a bad
animation but it looks really cool
yeah and this thing is like it's super
key because there are tons of cliffs in
this game and you know you you break a
new horse or you get a new horse and you
can't stop that easily without you know
this kid
you might fly off the cliff and die with
your horse yeah I'm sure we'll see some
of the physics so you can also do I
always kind of get strong so with like a
level four you can also do like rearing
like that right yeah well that's level
one oh it is that at level one level
four you get you get drifting the other
big one is like when if you want to do
some stealth stuff you seen the bottom
right there like sometimes your horse
will just you know cuz he loves you he
or she loves you will follow you so like
you'll you'll want to like be like stay
or maybe get out of here and say yeah
which is really helpful and then you
someone wants this crime says can you do
me a favor can kill a wild animal and
wait for its body to attract other
animals we can certainly try that at
some point we might be waiting for
awhile
any word on the microtransactions no I
have a feeling all those will come for
the online when that launches I think
they said November I don't know if
they're doing a date but sometime in
November
Oh lag so should we kill maybe kill one
of them this is this one yeah
any story story spoilers no we won't be
doing any story missions we're just
gonna be screwing around in the world
hopefully that helps still out tape says
he didn't see lag okay oh okay we don't
know how to see the CPU usage I don't
know if that's anyway so someone want to
see the map so here's what I have seen
so far so this is psalm denis not st.
denis pick up that writes like a French
Louisiana New Orleans Bayou all those in
one mm-hmm roads kind of like your
plantation southern US town Valentine's
where you kind of start out Jenks
that's me asks can you revisit the old
map uh kind of there are areas you can
revisit like you start in your
Blackwater but you actually can't
venture into Blackwater for a very long
time because you're wanted dead or alive
can you swim yes you can swim but not
very far because it drains your core is
super fast so right now I have the HUD
kind of off or it's like dynamic so if I
push down on the d-pad I can like
casually look at it Oh something's going
on here so this game is all about
running into just events let's see what
this is a lot of people are asking what
we're playing some there's a ps4 / oh
can you bust out a pack of cigarettes
and smoke yeah we can
[Music]
like that little Deadeye for you oh he's
done is this worth upgrading to a ps4
Pro for I did I don't know it's worth it
though yeah I did just because I don't
know if you have a 4k TV probably that's
that be the reason right for even acts
box one - yeah if not I probably know I
think the game looks pretty dang good no
matter what you're gonna play it on oh
these guys gonna think I did it
I feel like this happens all the time
well especially if you're standing over
the body Xbox one X hold native 4k I'm
not sure it apparently it supposed to do
native 4k you want to see the horse
testicles so this is this is a female
horse well at a line we find a male
horse will do it so yeah at any point
you can like call out people so they're
releasing Keith says - they're releasing
the story mode and online on separate
times yes similar what they did with GTA
5 it'll be a couple weeks before online
so you're quick wheel is a huge part of
like just everything you do in the game
so you have you see their three they're
your weapons and that's thing too is
like everything you have is on your
horse right so you can only really carry
like two weapons at a time as you see
now that's it I only have my repeater
and my repeater I mean your two pistols
its two pistols so like you go up to
your horse and then you swap around with
your weapon so I'll take what do I like
here well this game come to switch I
feel like you're joking but no it won't
be coming to switch I mean at least not
on the release date on October 26 maybe
one day it comes a switch but I can't
imagine that ever happening so here's
something I wanted to see smoking so
smoking increases your Deadeye right yes
so almost sorry sometimes I get carried
away here are you trying to find
cigarettes
I was I did not care to wait it's right
here cigarette yeah it looks really cool
if it's when he likes it too and and
flicks it and I just like the best is
when he smokes like a whole cigar and
just talk yeah because it's you know one
puff and then I'm done
so canned food will like increase your
core meters there in the bottom left
guys you should show us how to smoke
cigarettes we just did unless you mean
in real life in that case nah yeah plus
we can't smoke cigarettes in this room
and be too hot you can't true all right
so let's go do this bounty hunt so
there's a guy in your camp
who is it Strauss oh let's hunt this
deer run it over okay someone wants know
if you can hog-tie yes you can hog-tie
and yes you can put a body on a train
track I haven't done it though I mean I
put a body on a train track but I
haven't like seen a train ran over / - I
tried to do it - and the train just
didn't calm it was kind of like yeah the
trains I think it was because I had a
bounty on me yeah I've noticed sometimes
it can be like there'll be no reason why
I can't take the train I'm not gonna
round this over but yeah I'm like Red
Dead one where you could press Start you
could track the train on the map which
which baseball amount right that one
right bedroo demson because I know
someone's gonna dammit
mention that you can't track it on the
map anymore
wow that thing nosedived yeah how
clunkiness and how clunky and has the
aiming compared to GTA 5 uh one thing I
like to say about Rockstar Games is that
they really are obsessive over the
animations so I feel like a lot of
people see that as the movement feeling
a little bit clunky I only noticed it
being clunky in small areas kinda like
The Witcher 3 and GTA 5 for that matter
but other than that I think it feels
pretty well in the shooting feels like
an improvement over GTA 5 which I
thought GTA 5 shooting looks pretty good
to begin with I don't know if other
people felt that way though yeah I think
it's it's definitely like enjoyable it's
not like it's not like bad at all
someone was saying first person first
person you know it's funny we were
talking with us the other day like just
like GTA 5 you have first-person or at
least later in GTI GTA after launch it's
it's hard I don't know I don't enjoy
that much but Lucy was saying that she
was using it when she goes indoors and
I've been doing it now and I actually
like prefer to do this it does a
movement feel better yeah because it's
just bar easier to pick up stuff I feel
like sometimes like yeah proximity of
the object is it can be difficult but I
mean it's cool to like you know get a
sense of perspective don't you just
spoke in first person
you got more cigarette I can drink
brandy oh that's pretty cool yeah it
does look pretty cool you grow a beard
in Red Dead - yep certainly can you
don't really see the cigarette but if it
was a cigar you'd see it yeah cause it's
so big I'll feed my horses little cakes
oh I like that that's pretty cool the
hair physics look cool yeah actually
when it's like windy and stormy you can
see if it's long enough even if it's
short you still see Arthur's hair move
about but if it's long
gagging begum rabbit can you kill a
bounty with bone arrow
yeah you can sure can well that's thing
is you don't necessarily I mean I don't
actually don't think I've maybe I've
killed it I've done like two or three
bounties but you know it's wanted dead
or alive right so like I'll I'll hog-tie
that that SOB and bring them back we got
a good question here from REM are there
any glitches have you running any
glitches um yeah I've run into a few
I've run into some I mean they're in the
grand scheme of things grand scheme of
things that they're net it's not that
bad then it's you can totally look past
it but I I've been noticing ones where
it's like I feel like I'll turn around
or like enter a room and like it looks
like em NPCs will spawn in a little late
like I see that often and it's slightly
distracting but it's not that big of a
deal yeah I haven't really there's no
there's been no crashes no like game
breaking glitches like you're saying
that by super minor in most games you
probably wouldn't notice but because
this game is so like realistic and
detailed you know kind of notice those
so this is a cinematic camera so like if
you for whatever reason or you know you
got a long journey ahead and you got to
go to your actual fridge and get some
food just kind of set a waypoint and
then like hit the Simak camera and just
like let it go that's what I do I'd be
like yeah like go the bathroom yeah go
to the bathroom I'd text or something
only later in the game do i I really
used this early on I was kind of more in
the world but yeah the game is quite
long yeah and especially since if you
probably talked about it like you played
like or b-line the story for the most
part I'm letting the story took around
50 product 40 45 hours a lot that's a
lot of hours someone can easily spend a
hundred hours just getting through the
story and messing around yeah doing all
the sides maybe not a hundred hours but
probably like 80 hours yeah I've been
doing a lot of
you know like that's the thing is like
we saw that stagecoach robbery like
that's like probably the lowest tier of
like I know you could call them event
or like encounters but some of them are
like very well done like handwritten and
those are like you know the strangers
from the last game where it's like a
mini SciQuest but it's generally like
really well well done we have another
one fast travel so there is fast travel
there's one way fast travel well there
are tricky so you can't just like go to
your map and click on a point in fast
travel you can take a train that's fast
travel you can take a stagecoach that's
fast travel or if you unlock something
for your camp you can fast travel to a
settlement from there however you can't
fast travel back to your camp so it's
right it's interesting it there is fast
travel but it's very grounded within the
world right so like which I like yeah a
lot cuz the world is beautiful there's
always things to do when you're going
places for sure like it does so far for
me it has not been like frustrating at
all so yeah your post office is not only
where you take a train it's where you
pay off a bounty of that's on your head
and then you have your stagecoach which
is they're basically the same they're
just like different points right like a
stagecoach will bring you to a town and
then the train that will have like a
town but also just random stops yeah it
looks like Wallace station or middle
ring so yeah Ricky Magus I was going to
get this gaming until I got a 9 now I'm
not sure uh I mean I would I 9 is a
superb I think we call it superb on our
scale and the game is superb
so I wouldn't necessarily let that turn
you off of the game yeah if only this
was on pc yeah I bet one day it'll be on
PC I don't think they'll pull a red dead
one where it never came PC I mean if you
look at something like GTA 5 which is
still the top selling well maybe for
only so much longer but GTA 5 is slate
was you know still yeah like top-selling
game of all time
and you look at what that game did right
yeah it's launched on 360 it had its
other launch again with first-person for
the current gen Xbox one and ps4 and
then PC so three times yeah and I think
like especially looking at GTA 5 rocks
that really took their time and that PC
port was really good like you could you
could tweak that game a lot and plus
there were mods I have a feeling we'll
get it eventually it'll just the reason
it's taking so long is because they want
to make sure it's perfect and gives PC
players a lot to mess around with and
change in and adjust oh man yeah when it
eventually hits PC I'm sure it'll look
so good
can we play digitally I don't know what
you mean by that many clothes we have a
digital version of this game we don't
have a disc version and we can play it
if that's what you're asking
that's that it's like such an it it's so
fun to do that just to call out people
why going into a town in person you just
and recognizing people talk to yeah I
mean I play like a pretty good boy but
like lately I've been kind of slipping
cuz this thing is like you know I like
to compare it you know it's got some RPG
elements right but like you want to
compare it sometimes to like a Mass
Effect or a Witcher right but there it's
you are pausing you were making a
decision here there is no pausing like
you are you are quick thinking and a lot
of times you screw up and it's all your
fault yeah if you take too long they'll
get mad right so that yeah we got a
bunch of questions here what happens
your horse can you fast travel it'll
follow you yeah it'll follow you or if
you fast travel from camp
you just take your horse with you so you
have things like sorry off here things
like campfires
oh yeah thing too is you always have to
brush your horse alright a wants me to
check slack okay you brush your horse to
make it clean and then it makes it happy
and it makes it run faster and better
and now my horse is taking it down okay
today I did it
[Music]
so you see here like a campfire and you
know it's
it's meant to lure you to see what it is
like you know hmm what's that check it
out there will be multiplayer it's this
guy this guy so we saw the preview of
this game and this dude I'll just let it
speak for itself so you got a girl
mister what's it to you
me neither
I was north of Ana's burg when I came
across this cabin and there's no one
there but this woman mid boney but
beautiful as the day is long real
elegant fancy tattoo I see how you like
I'm to friend don't know what she's
doing out there in the middle of nowhere
but turns out she's a widow she asked me
to leave but in a real nice way made me
feel good I watched her from the bushes
for a while SAR cry I won't tell you
then if that's how you want to be if
ladies ain't your thing which I do to
him guys this guy's a clearly a perv
here's first person he smiles ask again
please this dude is a is a creep burn
him please I don't think I've ever
burned anyone oh okay I got I got this
sorry we're having a little bit of
technical issues with Facebook streams
and kind of sort that out no worries
please answers there director mode no
there is not a director mode holy cow
just burn that guy yeah you miss it Dan
so I am NOT messed with fire like it
looks pretty freakin good yeah
propagating it I mean dang oh dang look
at it's burning sorry yeah you keep
doing you know I think we're getting it
look my horse is freaked out cause of
the fire so yeah you stole your horse
will get spooked all the time by like
alligators and and other like predators
and apparently fire
okay I think we're good now they want
you to burn yourself apparently it's
pretty gruesome though and like if a guy
into a fire something like that in this
game and in real life I assume Oh wants
to see photo mode that's really a good
one to show oh sure
unless you have any spoilery photos I
doubt it though can your horse die yes
it can if you don't have like a horse
survivor your horse can die and you you
won't get it back and all that work you
put in will be for naught which makes
like I'm sure is happen to you is like
you panic well there is there's a lot of
contextual nature to crashing on your
horse like if you just like you can't do
whatever you want like you can't just
like beeline it through Rock a Rocky
Mountain or a forest because a branch
will knock you off your horse like yeah
it is it is gruesome and every time that
happens your horse goes down I like I'm
waiting for this moment where it's like
my horse won't get back up and I'm gonna
freaking cry alright sorry so I have the
camera here didn't do a selfie I can do
a selfie actually it's not really a
selfie but it's just if you want to get
your boy Arthur in the shot look at that
Clint Eastwood look I feel like I got
like dirt on my lip from smoking or
something yeah yeah expressions their
poses do you need to use the toilet
sometime no you don't you do need to eat
though so if you got the dlc horse it
can die and it's gone I bet you probably
buy it from from a stable start a forest
fire I don't know if the fire will get
into that intent
yeah we kind of saw it fizzle out
eventually can you wound your horse yes
you can
I hope he yells at you for being an
idiot in there is saying hi is this ps4
ps4 Pro this is a pro how about frame
rate House frame rate Ben for you it's
been pretty steady for me there was one
cutscene where I was where it just like
tanked but right after that cutscene it
was fine but that's like my only issue
with frame rate apart from like maybe a
drop here there and some bigger missions
bathing is big so you smell someone's
asking about bathing so yeah you you
smell and people will call you out like
if you don't shower or sorry just bathe
you go you can go to like a hotel and
take a bath or I think you get maybe we
should take a bath at some point yeah we
should I think I think it helps a little
bit if you jump in the water
because you can also like get dirty and
people react differently or if you have
like if you walk into town you're
covered in blood everyone's gonna like
freak and lose their mind alright I've
got two good questions here the first
one is is the fame and honor system like
in Red Dead Redemption one is it in this
and if so does affect the gameplay in
any way yes it is as you can see Rob
just brought it up and down there at the
bottom you can see kind of where
Arthur's alignment is so characters will
respond you different shops will give
you discounts depending on your fame and
honor people in your camp will respond
to you differently so it affects
gameplay it affects more I don't wanna
spoil too much but like Arthur is a
journal and that will change depending
on your honor which is neat and then
another question is the combat mechanics
more closer is the combat mechanics
closer to GTA 5 or Max Payne 3 I would
say Max Payne 3 just because you can
only carry a limited amount of weapons
and you can even dive if you want to
which is kind of cool yeah it's like a
light dive nothing to it reason like
slow down but you can at least like
combat dive out of the way I was trying
to see if I could do it okay I can show
you real quick
it's kind of funny we were joking around
cuz I was trying to do it so we dive
into the usual dive into the river okay
perfect and there's some swimming - oh
I've got some blood washed off I'll try
it again I was trying to do Deadeye as
well Wow
however the NPC's do they live there
live and stuff like that
yeah they seem pretty lively they go
about their thing they'll comment on
Arthur and chat with them if you want to
chat with a more you just insult them
any minigames poker
ton of mini-games fishing one of them
I've seen blackjack poker the was a
point five finger fillet dominoes so
here's some fishing the fishing is
really intuitive there's a lot there's a
lot you have to consider mm-hmm uh bait
type it's like far cry 5 I don't know if
it's better or worse than far cry 5 but
I think it's better than for cry 5 yeah
probably a little more to it in my
opinion oh yeah
do you play five finger fillet and
liar's dice five finger fillet yes
liar's dice i haven't seen yet I hope
you can play liar's dice liar's dice was
great I think someone said on slack that
they were able to so someone Eddie we
are one of our news guys in the au I've
been only catching fish like this big he
caught a legendary fish that was
gigantic
like this big it was hilarious he's got
this grizzly Mountain Man beard and the
photo he took it's a it's not standing
there are like legendary animals in
different areas so if you look at your
map and you know those obviously weren't
like like these are the legendary
animals so you go there the hunting is
very extensive where you have to like
track the scent with it's called eagle
eye yeah it's eagle eye or eagle vision
or evil vision so you see there the
streaks coming from me that's your own
smell so if you don't bathe
an animal can can catch wind of you or
and you can alert it so you want to like
mask yourself
yeah or there's the I forget what it is
but you can get like a decent thing that
you can put on if you wanna bathe right
which by babe
show the gore please yeah you should use
your shotgun on this dude all right anon
[ __ ] I may be not on him unless you want
to I don't know this guy's this guy's
giving you [ __ ] man I'll show you some
gore you got it gotta aim for the head
yeah no gore it can be tough there is
certainly gore but oh yeah let's just
say that like a shotgun that very close
range to someone's face it doesn't leave
much laughing it's almost easy a bar
fight man there's a lot there's a lot of
questions and things people want to see
Oh someone was saying can you flip
shoulder yeah you can flip shoulder like
that with the left left on the d-pad can
you take your gang members on missions
with you they'll take you on missions
I never and there was never there was
never like I don't know an opportunity
where the choice to bring one along with
me usually was like they're either there
they're not oh so what's important there
is I'm pretty sure that's what happened
is that your your honor will go down
what would you call it going what is the
act of going down I don't know at all
well like what is theirs I know there's
any ways in that event with that guy he
fired first right oh yeah yeah so if he
fires first then I won't like the meter
won't go down for me I want like I won't
it wasn't a bad act I was just giving
him [ __ ] and and do it can you loot an
enemy yes you can't oh dang so I went
hero I pre-order but why can't I play oh
we got early copies courtesy of Rockstar
in order to do a review and
stream create content around something
you guys get the game you'll know
exactly what you should do show more
gore not satisfied yeah that wasn't a
good one I was let's see if we can get
it here this is a this is quite the
fight though
oh I haven't done this yet and I should
just drink this a lot of people want to
see you go to a brothel
I don't think unless you can't like some
of the bars like they're usually like
prostitutes there but Arthur's not
interested kinda like Marston how
Marston was like I'm a married man
whenever they'd ask him yeah
Arthur just kind of says not interested
in walks away yeah well your change yeah
and then people want to see a bar fight
oh we are eat that
well I wouldn't say leave the stream but
there is a bar fight on our YouTube page
don't ya
site that is pretty awesome to happen to
me
against a local drunk who I called
raccoon man okay here's a good question
from lief Ford's he says is there
anything you can't do in the game that
you wished you could like within reason
I don't know I I think I had something
the other day I was thinking about but I
can't think of anything what about you
hmm that is a good question I didn't he
would answer what couldn't get my I
guess I have good no idea okay
my statement is low cuz I smokes many
cigarettes what can I eat
or take to get my stand screwed yourself
over here I don't know that thing will
Candis yeah oh I know something I wish
you could do I at least from what I
found you can't really rob a bank
outside of story missions at least not
that I found out maybe if I throw
dynamite at the the great the graded or
I can yeah but like I've I've gone into
banks and pulled my gun out like alright
and the the person behind the counter
will just freeze and law come in is
their 80s in first-person mode I don't
know I don't think so yes there is other
we're gonna thanks catch I already got a
copy but let's do man thank you thank
you hole weapons are coming yeah sorry
I'll get it I'll get some gore here
maybe there's your course yes pretty
much all weapons are customizable most
of the customization options don't
actually affect like the gun stats there
are a couple things that do but a lot of
them urges cosmetics what do you think
of the story so far so without spoiling
I think this is the best story rockstars
ever told yeah that's all I'll say
but but if you like story in games this
is definitely going to be a standout
with my coffee everywhere good so you
can dual wield Oh am i standing there
that well is this the new game yeah
comes out tomorrow or tonight if you're
very excited
so that's limit well that was also from
Max Payne 2 yeah so you can also get
attachments to weapons so like this one
I have a scope on it so I should be able
to yeah there is so so previously it
wouldn't let me do this but because I
attached a scope to it I could get the
scope call me Trinity wants to know who
were fighting
we're fighting some outlaws so this is a
bounty so I found a bounty poster and
were you going and now I'm here but it
looks like the guy has some backup and
remember if you guys want to check out
three of you the review is up and we
have a ton of Red Dead stuff already up
and more coming in the next few days
make sure to keep a lookout for that and
we do stream every day at 11:00
we're just doing a little bit early
because we know this is a big game you
guys are all excited for it and I'm
excited to finally talk about it openly
yeah feels good is there cheat codes yes
there are but we don't know any of them
there's a cheat code menu but we haven't
figured it out
don't have to wait for the the guide for
that so you also have different ammo
types there which you can craft at camps
or buy in stores
someone's to know how the physics are
robbed I think you need to run into a
tree just to show him okay
I don't see your horses as my head has
enough health but so I throw dynamite at
this guy
so look at that a lot of people don't
know if you can smoke cigarettes yep
before we smoked a lot people really
want to know that like I throwing arm I
threw a dynamite at him look at his hand
oh my god look at his finger his fingers
like all like broken and oh don't play
with dynamite a cute faster like in Far
Cry 5 yeah we kind of talked a lot about
fast travel it's a little bit different
than most games you can't just pick a
point on a map and go there you need to
pay for it be a train or oh wow more
coming
this is this is cool I want this game
but I don't have the money hopefully
yeah this is I would be bummed
I'll give this guy limping the thing is
cuz I throw dynamite again whoops run
into a tree yeah we're gonna do it I'm
gonna convince Rob he just needs to hi
you someone else's horse yeah you
someone else is fine question rival
gangs yes there are many rival gangs
there's one that you interact with a lot
through the story and for a while I
thought that was the only gang but as
you play you will come across other
gangs and how they perceive you can
change depending on depending on your
actions to them most of them don't like
you though because you're a gang
yourself
got to be rivals how's the first person
I don't typically use it I think third
person is much better just because the
animations are so good and the detail is
great but if you really like first
person it seems like it works well yeah
running the tree for the physics trust
me you'll get a good sense as well
there's a good sense of the physics but
yeah you'll get a good sense of the
physics if we run into a tree did you
order from the rock star warehouse to
get it early and no oh this is a review
copy provided by rockstar is arthur
morgan a good character I don't know if
I'd call him a good person but I think
he's a very good character yeah yeah is
the combat always so easy yeah it's not
too hard I would say it's not too hard
but you can find yourself real quick in
a pickle yeah like I think when it's
hard is when you're taken by surprise
yeah yeah totally like sometimes I'll
come across a like I'll just be writing
and they'll be an ambush waiting for me
and that's usually when I will uh I will
die
is there difficulty levels I don't think
so
question how long will the stream be up
like how long will you stream your how
long oh let's say on YouTube I have a
feeling this will probably stay on
YouTube will probably stream I don't
know probably for quite a while oh I
thought I got the wrong corpse is this
the best rock star game in my opinion it
is I don't know Rob what do you think is
this year yeah yeah yeah this game
consistently just blows my mind it will
the story has some really cool surprises
that's all I'll say
how does the world compared to The
Witcher 3 there's one question that
reminds me of butcher 3 right here at
this hole the yeah the world is like
very detailed it's wild there's like a
frontier
the NPCs react to you in a different way
I'd say this is a little bit more fluid
how many pcs react to you and how you
can interact with them but I don't know
I think it just depends like do you
prefer a fantasy world or do you prefer
I don't know why that's entertaining and
really is yeah
do you prefer like a fantasy world or
you more into realism crap um I like
realism fancy not so much
I do like sci-fi but this works did like
the vegetation this game is so freakin
good like they're just these moments
where we're going
do these mana mana if you like are you
like my favorite moments are wearing
your out of camp and you like go to
sleep and cuz you know you need to sleep
in this game and you wake up and it's
like no you don't need to sleep in this
game you don't know you don't you don't
have to there's nothing making you sleep
but if you sleep it'll refill your cores
oh oh yeah huh okay I guess wasn't
thinking
technically you like don't have to do
anything but like it's good to eat it
but like if it's night like wreck right
now I mean I'll just why do I have to
talk about I'll just do it yeah you
could set up a campsite although you are
delivering a carcass
I mean he's dead how do you dead bodies
react to a shotgun in the face I don't
know where did always there crime that
sounds like an herit question I don't
know what type of weather is available
oh you have people following you there's
there's thunderstorms rain snow
snowstorms foggy lightning is really
cool the Lightning is really cool I've
only seen it once
apparently the weather will change
depending on Arthur's weather he's
honorable or dishonorable and I'm pretty
honorable so are you I haven't seen many
storms and I think maybe it's because I
am
generally a good boy yeah I feel like
I'm talking a lot with all these
questions no you're doing
can you bring fellow gang members with
you for side quests no but fellow gang
members will bring you along for side
quests I don't know if they can help
with bounties to be honest I never
really tried to like go up and see if a
gang member wants to come with me
but I've never really seen the option so
is Mexico in a game getting a lot of
questions about that
playing find out like Blackwater and
West Elizabeth is in the game okay this
guy's asked this question a lot can you
romance no apparently you didn't dan
Houser say that that was going to be a
thing where they cut it it was like
there was like to direct to romance
storylines maybe I wouldn't be surprised
because now I I want to say too much
mm-hmm
how long does the install take well my
friend that's gonna depend it took me
around four hours and it was doing about
100 megabytes a second no I didn't take
that long it took about three hours in
between about 80 megabytes a second but
it is 92 gigs on PlayStation I think 90
gigs on Xbox can you smoke yes you can't
got the smoking that's cool with a match
at night yeah the lighting is really
good and the lighting is lighting
incredible in pretty much every way like
any type of light always looks good like
I really love how blue night looks but
then you see like I like that you see
like that nice warm orange like light
like I don't know it looks gorgeous
that's I was gonna say it doesn't look
like I can do it right now but when you
when you set up camp and then like you
go 4:00 in the morning and you're just
in the woods and there's that that
morning mist or you just see like yeah
because the Sun is so low that it's just
in your
face blinding with like silhouetted
trees it's like it's pretty stuff takes
you away like how long is the game I
played only the starting to ruin took me
around 40 hours well I played a little
bit of stuff but mostly the story in
took around 40 hours like damn look at
that lighting yeah so this is a Sam
Denis you correct me the first time
because I didn't hear something Tom
Denis look I got blood all over me
unfortunately uh just a smudge yes I did
can you go to armadillo yes you can this
is my favorite town so far that I've
seen it's so yeah this is like the hub
I'd think a game it's so meticulous like
everything like is so good-looking every
building just looks so freakin awesome
do you know if this game supports 5.1
surround sound I'm pretty sure it does
house keeps all caps having saves this
is what your saves will look like if
you're like me I'm saving a lot isn't
different you can you there are more
slots than this I don't know why oh it's
just cuz you hit load hit load so I
don't know how many that's probably like
more than enough 20 yeah more than
enough you get fat so I actually never
ate enough for Arthur to get any
noticeable noticeably bigger apparently
you can make him bigger by eating but I
don't you know so you go to player here
I'm on the same go with you I'm not
eating that much I feel like I got ended
up pretty underweight just cuz I got to
the point I like I like eating doesn't
really do much to like I just didn't
care
right so if you are overweight you're
gonna lose stamina and if you're
underweight
you're gonna lose health mm-hmm all
right more questions where is this
taking place so this takes place like
the the west's kind of to the deep south
I would say like the what like new alley
or was it is it West Elizabeth and new
Elizabeth I don't know that's like the
west where Blackwater is and then all
the way here we're kind of in the deep
south and son Denis which is kind of
like like nollans West Elizabeth yeah
West Elizabeth there we go
New Orleans oh yeah well we'll go into a
bar after this 60 frames a second on
conf I don't think so this isn't steam
60 frames can you enter every interior
no you can enter a line though did you
see lightning I felt like I saw anything
maybe was a glitch look like a flash you
show us the map we just did some of
these comments why do so many yeah
that's part of it
strip club nope no strip clubs don't say
nollans sorry can you go in every
building we got another one of those
quests morning it's not way to kill this
could a hey I think Tay asked for that I
don't know try that again
I'll turn that back on
okay I'm putting a dead body in jail
you're playing on ps4 Pro taking a bath
takes kind of long we didn't show that
after this actually
[Music]
apparently slack today I am
can you get kidnapped I in this town I
was uh I was lured into an alley once
some guy was like hey man like it was so
obvious he was gonna rob me but I was
like yeah I'm thinking like yeah I'll
like pull my gun out first and I one of
his buddies came up behind me and
knocked me out and they were like
totally robbed me like people can take
advantage of you it's not it's not so
easy sometimes to to have the upper hand
like you can get and get school it's the
pull here
how do you do that
hey partner alright let's take a bath
and then let's get in a bar fight or no
let's get in a bar fight first oh I've
never gone to a show have you done that
yet sorry you're busy I have gone to a
show it's pretty cool but it's long it's
probably near as bar this looks like a
good place you want to are you trying to
look at that yeah apparently it stopped
working
I know the preview if you are previewing
something it will slow down but oh yeah
I'm gonna kill it I just want to add
everyone just looking at me because I
have blood all over me
that's dude standing on a chair
Oh what we're people on the track we are
having some slight technical issues
we'll work on it good now I think we
might be good at so he's getting down
now man you robbed the saloon yeah yeah
oh man all the cheat codes are up oh wow
oh no way this guy's gonna rat on me
okay hold on go to the cheats menu oh I
didn't need to do that oh you better hog
time I well if you have your lasso out
and you can ox one down you
automatically hog time Oh God
cheats menu should I do that right now
do you really want to cheat sir now
well hold on oh I'm gonna I'm gonna tell
you what to enter I'm not gonna tell you
what it does I'm just gonna take you to
enter it we want to do cheats right now
though yeah we want a did you try that
okay it'll be funny all right maybe not
right now but we should do it at some
point it's not spoilery it's just like
your honor
okay so g-codes Maybank can i yeah let's
let me eliminate this honda wanna save i
would save you did that one bounty but
you also just murdered a couple cops
you probably load an autosave yeah it's
good call yeah i just load up an
autosave okay never and they're saying
they're saying no cheat it's the what
I'm gonna have meant there isn't really
a cheat it's more of just something
funny yeah if you guys really don't want
cheat it's not like invincibility or
anything breaking it's just like it'll
be funny we can we can put some gameplay
up layer of some cheats I'm sure
um I don't know I think you'd be pretty
funny though well I'll tell you what
I'll load this autosave I'll do a manual
save will do the cheat and then I can go
back all right all right all right give
me a second can you change a different
third person yeah if you had the
touchpad I think the camera will kind of
adjust fighting first person I should
I'll do that okay all right settings and
now hit triangle and now hit triangle
again capital a space and then fool on
command full on command fool fol space
space on command so I hope you don't see
it because it'll be funnier sheep don't
and then yeah yeah that's to be it
scroll down oh yeah bang that's all it
was I was hoping you just like flip to
being drunk
and so you just fight drunk look at this
face he looks so toasted scanner fight
in the first person no we'll go back and
save a drunk bar fight in first person
yeah okay all right fine gonna have to
be a bar fighting I like the other bar
it's it's got a it's got people like
Mike I know those upper-class folk is
this game worth buying yeah yeah I would
say absolutely I like just the fact
alone at how much content there is like
if you're one of those people who
doesn't Bluff if you can only afford to
buy like one game at a time or you don't
have the time to play all these games
this is a good one because it's all one
game you can get that will keep you
entertained for a very long time
yeah I didn't know that you can't ride
your horse drunk do you get high like in
GTA you can do cocaine well kind of you
can have chewing gum chewing chewing it
I'm Jim I'm too drunk to ride my horse
Carl or Carl or my horses name all right
maybe you should just reload back to the
other safe all right
that was as funny as I hoped but no
that's pretty good well that's cool that
and also that looked like a lot of
cheats yeah I didn't want to read the
other ones but there didn't do that one
just seemed funny so I was like yeah do
you need to play the first one in order
to get this one yes and no I would say
if you've played the first one you'll
probably appreciate this game a lot more
especially if you're a big fan of the
first I think this game does some like
has some incredible fan service but the
story is good regardless I'd say and the
world is beautiful the game is fun like
you're not gonna you're not gonna not
like the game cuz you can play at first
but if you can't I'd recommend playing
the first or or if you don't play the
first but you want to know what happens
we have a pretty rad video it's about a
10 minute long recap of the first one
do you smoke a cigarette whenever you
like yes you can oh my god people with
cigarettes
I know hilarious how about this bourbon
I love that animation he just spits up
the cap and just drinks it arose it I
really wish I had some cigars I can go
buy something to show the store actually
God that looks so cool where's my horse
hey baby
is the whole map open straight away most
of it is there's a part which
technically you can go into but you're
gonna get shot real quick so here oh my
god what octan is referencing something
that I get I wish I didn't get the
hunting is really good I want to see the
cocaine chewing gum do you have any
cocaine chewing gum so if you go to item
let's go okay sure
oh you mean like my satchel no you
should have it ready too if you go here
too right yeah you can you can find it
there as well I think that's it right
there to the right there yeah there you
go
I am a work
ah I can show a general store you should
run into a telephone pole or something
though all right I'll just do that now
and get out of the way remember that
tree right there so that's the police
being right into this tree oh I like it
go I liked it better when like you fly
for like if you hit a fence fare like
this it's not gonna go well
oh oh oh I feel so bad for Carl or here
are there any duels yeah there are duels
I can't lift myself I'm going back and
save oh he's fine
he still likes you are you okay
he's easy level four already I feel like
a dick I mean you are a kind of a dick
but
oh yeah brush um make up for it maybe
maybe give them a little snack a little
yea snack an apple maybe a Napa
sorry baby oh crap is there a train
coming they want to know if you can sit
on share yes you can sit on chair it's
not all chairs but appreciate you can
see I'm pretty much all your chairs at
your camp there's no one care about
something you can swim actually I think
if you want you can there's a there's a
water behind you can jump in if you want
to show them but it's there yeah you can
push people over just by running into
him yeah it's like the first game was
kind of like that too right uh yeah
kinda I think this is the general store
no it's not is the protagonist as
memorable as John Marston I would say
yes I think Arthur Morgan is a more
interesting character than John Marston
however I do like John Marston more cuz
I kind of think he is I don't know I
just have such a high spot place for him
after playing the first game all those
years ago he's stuck with me is one of
my favorite videogame protagonists
however Arthur Morgan is more
interesting more subtle better written
John Marcin in this game is awesome Joe
Marcin this game is awesome
he's like a completely different person
like you you you really get to see him
grow yeah alright you get a sense of how
he's grown to a better person and read
an one as this is a prequel but he's
such a dick Abigail always gang in
fights
oh the other cool thing is like so
buildings will be constructed over time
yeah I don't know if all of them will
like I yeah maybe not them but there's
like certain buildings that you'll see
that when you start out it'll just be a
frame and by the end of your game it'll
be built which is rad yeah like I've
already seen like a house like almost
completion and it's really interesting
too because I was what you in Valentine
did you go you ever see that that like
family to south the guy with two sons
anyways like they are legit picking up
pieces of wood and like you see the nail
going in to the piece of wood and
another one like they are it's
impressive
like it really looks like they are
building a house where are we
I will show a general store cuz it's
pretty cool like the catalog and stuff
is it true this game is over 100 gigs no
that's not true it's under it's barely
under a hundred gigs that is better
it's tumbleweed a ghost town I don't
know you have to go there for yourself
and find out there was one time where
see if you sprint into a door do you
like bust through there was a general
store of accents sprinting in and did
that and shattered the windows of the
door and you guys like what do I help
stick of gum please so yeah you can do
two things you can go around and just
like pick things out I really like the
first person in stores and in doors do
the controls seem similar to GTA 5 yes
they are however this game there are
more controls you have to know like the
whole context menu it's a little more
complicated like it took me like I
didn't know until I finished the game
that if you ho try and go our thrill
just take any and rest yeah I have no
idea I don't want you to sit on a chair
so you can sell stuff here I'll
generally sell some of these guys oh you
got to clean your guns - that's a big
thing I've done oh well I'll do that the
catalog is really neat frame that keeps
tipping up for us maybe it's the stream
can you do all yes you can how often do
you use the r-1 button in the game there
are I mean that's that's like how you
stop how you do Dead Eye how you do Dead
Eye
well it's how you tell you target
targets yeah so this is the if I had a
lot of facial hair you buy that stuff
and look how eloquent you didn't get it
now if you want to grow your beer a
little bit quicker it takes a while
otherwise what's the miracle just health
yeah that's just health they want you to
rob the shop owner
is it more fun in third or first I'd say
third did you get to see all the details
of Arthur it's like pretty cool you get
to see what you know he does with his
weapons and stuff I'd well let's sit
down first if I really want to do that
do they really don't want me to rob this
guy one person said that way more people
have asked you to sit down though what
things people want us to do like I was a
dancer I'm done asking questions no
answers sorry there are a lot of
questions going through what question do
you have I'll see if I can find it
where's a it looks like I can't find
this should be good oh yeah there you go
doesn't think you can sit down in these
chairs but you can rest by the fire so
chairs at your campground you can sit
down in may be sure to start resting by
fire see if oh wait did he sit in it I
think I'm sitting not a chair though so
yeah it looks like it's only chairs at
your campfire certain or at you none of
your campfire you're at your camp yeah
cuz generally you can sit down to like
well no you can go into bars and I think
do it let's go to a bar we keep talking
like that have you guys tried the phone
app yet is it available I can download
it if it is available
then want you to smash the door open
into this door all right I'll do that
that's what I'll do although man I feel
bad if you ask another question crime it
probably got buried all right here watch
this this this this door will totally
break oh did it the hell oh maybe not
this phone it did end what another place
oh there's a lot of people saying robbed
store robbed store I'll go to the bar
and I'll gain a bar frame and I'll rob
the bar and then I'll book it out you're
not able to rob the bar if you get in a
bar fight first though [ __ ] I don't see
the app available yet unless I don't
know the name of it oh man just just
read dead - there's something going on
here where was it
yeah it may not launch until the game
launches is combat as is the combat rag
doll is in the first game yeah it does
all right I'll Rob him
Maisie says don't rob him no not him
he's a poor beggar Rob why would you
even consider that
I know people people were saying earlier
to go do first-person bar fight but I'll
just Rob this guy and I'll leave one guy
says swimming equal death question mark
no you can swim in this game however it
drains your core super fast so you can't
like you can't hop in the water and swim
across the lake but you can take canoes
and row boats sell out and jump in front
of a train kill the sheriff but not his
deputy comment so far all right let's do
this
uh let's think you pull your gun out
people look someone wants to see the
pistol reload animation oh I got clean
my gun - I'll show that and do that
right now so you gotta clean your gun
it's important can you build your cue
build your own home buy a business you
can't buy businesses like in GTA you
can't buy your own home your home is
kind of like the camp that moves around
the map it doesn't move around the map
but the camp that your your gang hangs
out at your gang hideout
you can rent rooms in towns and saloons
so if you need to stay the night
somewhere or if you want to just change
your clothes and you're really far from
camp you can just rent the room and do
it there do NPC interactions change when
you're drunk yes Arthur slurs his words
and people will be like get your act
together app doesn't come out until
midnight all right there it is crime
reported crime is really guilting me oh
you son robbed the register
is this Xbox or ps4 this is PlayStation
4 pro cool shot the register cool times
sorry what how'd that guy get up is hell
no I haven't done this yet how about a
nice tomahawk dang it
can you drive the Train I don't know
never tried that's why they call it red
dead so that's what dying is like yep
ask him for that yeah what dying was
like I just wanted to show that off see
yet somebody did someone wants to know
where you respond when you die
well dang it I knew I had to show
something like that so there it is you
lost a hundred bucks that I did actually
I lost a nine hundred ninety nine
dollars what no
oh do you call a gang member to come to
your aid no but if you're near a gang
member and you get in trouble they will
intervene and help you out it's actually
pretty cool oh yeah yes yeah we were
playing and I got in a fight outside and
some of my gang members were in a bar
and they rushed out and just like I was
in the middle of a fight and all of a
sudden a guy I'm fighting just gets shot
through the head the whole town just
gets like gets shot up in a second map
size map sighs all right I'll show map
size
this is also what the loading looks like
yeah yep towards the employees I asked
for that well you got it he got the
death
what else we want to do you go to the
old map please uh you'll see parts of it
I don't know I don't say too much though
this is the map I mean it this is
there's a lot more like this is
obviously areas I haven't explored yet I
went up to the mountains the other day
it's [ __ ] cool dude going back to
where Gahan star Nick Jesus thanks for
answering my questions cool I I hope I
answered your questions can't tell if
you're joking or not you get naked
unfortunately I was really hoping you
could like get Arthur down to his
underwear but you can't
here's a lantern that's cool map did you
just show the map but I wasn't
yeah I did okay
can you jump off a cliff with your horse
yes you can
it is not pretty this is not pretty at
all should we play poker that's kind of
boring
yeah poker can take a while is there
just like five finger fillet here that
might be a good one to do photo studio
yeah you can go get like nice photos of
Arthur taken like in front of backdrops
and everything I want to do that it's
pretty cool it's like I haven't seen
that if you wipe out an entire town will
it become a ghost town or all new NPC's
show up and start living there actually
don't know and that's something I do
want to try one day nice save they don't
know if you wipe out all the citizens in
a town does it become a ghost town jeez
I'm not entirely sure it's something I'm
definitely interested in trying
cuz I think it'll be really interesting
like if you kill a shopkeeper and you're
just like well you're not buying
anything from that shop anymore Oh
someone does want to see poker though
maybe we can do one handed poker let's
go to the photo studio and do one handed
poker
okay go all-in I'm right by the poker
poker place just do that real quick
all right go all-in go all-in yeah all
right
I'm just kidding don't go all-in
I was 2 grand
Robert vulgar says a lot of people stuck
on the horse nuts yeah people really
want to see horse nuts well I kind of
find a horse that has nuts don't I yeah
all right let's play bugger oh it's this
bar they love me uh Jesse Henshaw says
he how long does the tutorial take
around a few hours I'd say but I would
say that a lot of the a lot of the
tutorials come after like the tutorial
section I would say
ooh expensive I am buying ya the poke I
did play a lot of blackjack or Noah's
poker actually and blackjack but it it's
really good it is pretty good
I do miss at least that I found I miss
in red that Redemption you could there's
that suit where you could hide an extra
card up your sleeve
Oh reeling like blackjack with three
cards poker with three cards is really
good and like if you did it too much
they would start to notice and get mad
damn but I just like every poker game I
just wear that poker outfit and just I
have a card up my sleeve at all times
dude I bet they have that eye I'm
playing a lot of blackjack for poker
okay it's just like pears and full house
and stuff right so
[Music]
yeah we will violet they want you to
shoot up all these people show up ask a
question have it somewhat answered
immediately sweet happy to help I guess
I'll call man they really want us to
shoot up the table I don't thing we're
gonna shoot up the table because we'll
just reload saves there's the
consequences are far greater in this
game to be a psychopath unlike in red
that one and GTA do you name your horse
yes you name your horse I need my mom
yeah yeah yeah I named all mine Roche
yeah you did
what if I don't know how to play
blackjack well this is a good way to
learn I learned how to play poker and
blackjack through video games so I mean
I think the first kind of tutorial
mission for poker they don't they teach
you
kind of yeah not blackjack but like
poker Texas yeah it's Texas Hold'em yeah
if you lose kill them did we lose that
first pot i folders do so yeah can you
do a wield yes you can
oh you can do a wheel that was you being
excited yes you can
how about I said piece of dynamite on
this table okay oh and argue with that
all right
Siegen says roach yeah that's expected
whoa what do we have got two pair mm all
right now's your time all in baby all in
as much as you can
oh yeah cuz you're buying was five
dollars I mean it's net it's never a
good thing to go all-in people are just
gonna except for this this guy here
mister chops what does he have
pair of kings so do i dang oh he's got a
pair of kings in his hand anyone no I
want I'm sorry I got confused there oh
wait Oh cuz I two pair duh I saw his
jack and I got confused
yeah take a walk as I did not know if I
wanted hot all right should I I'm gonna
drop a drop a nice stick of dynamite on
this table
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh let's see the aftermath here oh my
god I'm waiting for the chat to catch up
and see
halie chairs were charred multiplayer
comes out in a week not right now I
think it's a little further than a week
and it is a beta but it'll be a couple
weeks I think which is good I mean
you're not gonna you're going to enjoy
this game like the story wanted for
disturbing the peace
yeah I guess that sound five dollars so
that is one thing that I want to say
that like it's like it never lines up or
a lot of times it doesn't line up
correctly is what you are wanted for
yeah like there was one time I got a bar
fight it was like vandalism I was like
what the hell like I didn't do anything
what was that for oh let's go to
Photoshop revolver references I actually
don't know I haven't found any Red Dead
Revolver references but I haven't played
that game in a long time or at least I
haven't finished that game a long time I
guess I kind of played it recently for
the history of but I haven't seen any
references so far but I haven't been
looking they're definitely references
the read that one I mean apart from the
fact that John Marston is in this game
but someone was asking if you can dance
you can't dance but sometimes you can
dance really you can dance
so occasionally there will be a party at
your tents or at your camp and he's
getting thrown out and you'll be offered
to to have a dance with one of the
ladies there can you stop the train yeah
you can stop the train
are there cheat codes yes there are are
there hookers yes but you can't interact
with them apart from like chatting with
them a guy's leg was blown off yeah guys
like was blown off
there's some there's some dirty work
dude I'm more impressed with how that
whole table like use the excuse me but
like the just a charred radius of like
an explosion I was like freaking cool
again people have definitely mentioned
Landon Ricketts I haven't seen him I
don't know if he's in it or not but I
want to see a one-on-one duel
have you ever gotten a duel yet I have
gotten a few but there are shooting
ghouls everybody don't happen that often
now they're kind of hard to find like I
feel like I wasn't that the case in the
last game when dreaded one we're like
you just kind of came across him like
you never necessarily like went just
someone to duel maybe someone on the
street who'd be like challenging yeah
and there has been that case before like
I was in a bar and someone challenged me
to a duel and they were drunk and passed
out but it was but yeah what is
character customization like there are a
lot of a lot of customization options
obviously you're stuck with Arthur that
being saying it's not like Red Dead one
where you just had outfits and this I
mean you can create out that though you
can grow out his hair beard I can change
my outfit you can change your outfit
down to everything it's not like red did
one where you just had outfits and this
I mean you can create outfits and have
those swap like that oh look at this hat
I had so if you go to our YouTube
channel there's a bar fight and this is
how I got that hat from a guy who was
wearing this raccoon man it's a pretty
good video it's pretty pretty cool and
wants to see you go to a barber here's
your winter outfit you have actually a
lot of like generic outfits at the camp
I noticed yeah you start with a lot yeah
I was surprised I only thought it was
like a couple and then whatever you go
by yourself but I guess it makes sense
though right these guys have yeah I have
some clothes there's some summer attire
here and then my fit which I like well
the whole horse always come to you if
it's not dead no if you're too far away
it will not come to you yeah
however I was looking at the cheats and
I believe there's a cheat you can turn
on that it'll come to you no matter what
so if that interests you if you think
that's annoying honestly though I didn't
think it was that annoying like crap
most of the time like even if I left my
horse in the dust it would still show up
at like after mission cutscenes shamily
this hat on man they really want you to
jump off a cliff with your horse there's
a bunch of sadists they just want the
worst all right I can do that after this
are there any ponchos I don't know I
haven't seen any ponchos I've seen
people
wearing Poncho's I think do you haven't
read news in the game there are
newspapers that you can pick up and read
do you have a mask yeah I actually
bought so yeah if you notice earlier
we're in about was my robbed the store I
had a bandana that's like the standard
one I believe I have I love how you when
you do loads or saves he's just like God
some pose going on I do have I believe a
different mask I bought I thought I had
it on maybe it's on my horse yeah there
are there are different mass mass
robbery ridiculous ones I got like a
skeleton mask I think oh here it is
oh yeah there you go so that's pretty um
I see a couple people saying they want
to see the barbershop maybe instead of
the photo place it might be good to
check out the barbershop right here oh
never mind Ben if we're here let's do
the photo you own a house no you cannot
oh wait I got my hat and not wear this
no you should wear the had the hats
funnier yeah the the raccoon has funnier
sorry about that I'm ready that's why
you're here did you call us that you
made a massacre yeah that's too serious
though for this I like that a little bit
more just hold hold on let me get my
beer bottle for this photo what
expression Joey can you explain the
weapon wheel into a wielding yes it is
actually kind of complicated I would say
so there's Arthur's weapon wheel there's
an item weapon wheel and there's a horse
weapon wheel your horse you obviously
need to be near your horse in order to
engage with that yes you have to be near
your horse to engage that and that has
things like you can change your outfit
eating etc Arthur's weapon wheel is for
weapons and once again to equip long
rifle
and weapons you need to be near your
horse and then finally the item weapon
which is just kind of a quick access to
things like cigarettes which everyone
seems to love things that will kill you
and food etc someone said hey Jake when
do you someone asked about online once
again online will be a couple weeks from
now turn up the game volume I can turn
up a little bit yeah sorry how
repetitive is the NPC die like when
walking down the street
it hasn't been too repetitive believe it
or not I mean if you can compare
anything to like GTA 5 it's there was no
in GTA 5 there was a lot of NPC dialogue
in here I think you remember the number
they said it's it was like something
ridiculous like like 30,000 dialogue
accorded or some crap like that yeah
they liked it it's pretty damn good oh
that's like to be fair though I think if
you spend 100 hours in this game you
will probably start to hear some things
repeated like I've heard something
repeated but it's never like like it's
still so far apart from each other that
it's not like I don't really notice yeah
rmally show horse pooping I don't know
if the horse if the horse wants to poop
it you'll see it if no I mean sometimes
you just gotta let it do its own thing
sometimes I'll be in a firefight and
I'll turn around I'll just be going
there you go I don't come in right on
command
how many side quests are there there are
a ton there are two kinds of side quests
if you don't count like the little small
interactions there are stranger missions
which show up on your map is big
question marks and then there are gang
members side missions which are white
and they usually show up in your camp
and if you go and talk to that gang
member they'll take you out to do like a
robbery or something and those are
pretty good because those actually have
cutscenes and usually you get a nice bit
of story or backgrounds these characters
okay so here's here's the weapon wheel
here's the weapon wheel again so you
hear my dual wheel wielding pistols I
got like a shotgun there's a volcanic
volcanic yeah you can swap those
independently right and this is when I'm
on my horse when I get off my horse it's
basically what I decided
so this is like these are the max amount
of things you can carry but because I'm
on a horse I can easily swap and pull
them out because everything I have like
I have a lot of weapons on my horse I
got like a sniper rifle here or a rifle
Oh someone to see weapon customization
we show that in the barber shop -
barmageddon' barbershop questions
someone also asked overall what do you
think of this game go rob I think this
is one of most impressive games I've
seen in forever I don't know like this
this this game will be around for a
while yeah like there is so much in this
game there's so much to do we haven't
even considered what the online is even
about I plan on playing this game like
for months and months and months
yeah is there so much to do you were
like we talk about like I don't think I
don't think in this office someone has
ever said like I'm gonna play this game
like immediately again and it's true
because you can play it immediately
again and like I think most people in
the office again are like playing as a
good guy you I would love to see what it
is if you go all-in on being an [ __ ]
like yeah I think that's what I'm gonna
do like right when I rolled credits I
was like alright I'm gonna play this
again like I I haven't started in game
yet cuz I'm gonna wait until I get my
xbox one special edition that I ordered
but I'm fully intend on playing this
again I think it like I said before I
think it's rockstars best game they've
made I think so too
oh and like you said I think it's the
most impressive game I've seen yeah
like it it reminds me a lot of The
Witcher 3 and that like the attention to
detail is so like unparalleled that like
it's so easy to just get lost in this
world yeah and like I'm not saying it's
perfect like it definitely has issues
like any game no game is perfect like
some of the pacing gets kind of weird
towards the middle I would say it's damn
near perfect right like in my opinion
yeah I think it's about as close as you
can get
like they really have set the bar once
again with this game like I mean it for
me like breath away last year its it
reminds me a lot of that in that it it
changes what you consider an open-world
game yeah I think there's probably more
discovery in a game like breath of the
wild yeah but I think like people will
still be talking about this game for as
long as breath awhile but maybe not for
the same reasons like I don't think
they'll be on Reddit sing like hey I
didn't know you could do this or I did
this crazy thing I think instead it'll
be like whoa this detail that I threw
six times and finally yeah noticed yeah
like one of the oh my god jump off a
cliff people really want that yeah so
the thing about your hair though is you
know if you want to compare it to gta5
is that I can't just like throw on any
kind of hair style imaginable if you see
in the bottom left there like that's the
length these are the options I'm given I
can only go shorter right yeah just like
in real life you can change the style a
little bit though too but it would still
be like short yeah the same length it's
somewhat generous there right like I
think this is what I had keep going down
to oh you're right yeah it's Max Payne
Witcher 3 is game of all time I I agree
that's all I have to say real men only
go bald you can definitely do that we
can do all the latest trends yeah these
are just great out cuz I don't have look
at that double-double for chin look at
that never even seen that in my life
that's that's a cheat that's a what have
you ever seen that before no it is the
weird it looks like a freaking beetle
one more thing I will say is that I also
think the story in this game is
phenomenal
yeah like there's some surprises that
only Rockstar could ever pull off I
think people are really gonna dig the
story oh I should have done this earlier
yeah the voice acting and the story it's
like so freakin good I find myself like
not like playing by myself like now many
times am i laughing out loud you know I
mean for at least a you know laughing
with the game I'm surprised how funny
some of these moments are like I don't
know like like the storytelling and and
the story is has such a diverse range of
like it's so funny and they can be so
emotional yeah and it's done really well
can you eat meal at a restaurant you can
eat meals at bars yeah at a saloons
gunsmith boy I am sorry there are a ton
of questions if I don't get to yours
probably cuz it got buried or because
I've answered it we can do her a dozen
times let's do a robbery we do a train
robbery that'd be pretty dope
is every building enterable no no but
there are a lot of buildings you can go
into I'm frequently surprised like a lot
of times I just come across a building
like out of nowhere and I'll be I don't
even go in and I'll just open the door
up and they'll be someone in there and
they'll be like what are you doing in my
house
but like you can't just go in every
single especially in this town because
it's pretty big oh man
now that's what I call a good day's work
is it based on real-world map Simone
America so it is the place is fictional
but it takes place in America and they
reference things like New York and
California and so on it kind of it's
like same thing that rock started with
the first Red Dead where it's like this
is a fictional area that takes place in
a real world some said can you break
into a house yeah like sometimes you'll
come across people in the world like I
came across this prisoner who's like
shutting shackles and I have freedom and
he was like hey I don't have any money
to give you but I do have a location of
like a really great house to rob and
they like shows up on your map
let's go to pen Smith now looks like
it's about to rain
it's all of the south no it's not well
though I mean it's it's a bit of a south
like we're in the South southern we're
in the southern part of America but you
can go to like the snow-capped mountains
which the snow in this game I think is
stunning yeah
like it reminds me a lot of like
uncharted - I remember the snow being
really good and uncharted - yeah but
seeing it on the scale of this is like
super impressive I think totally and you
know yesterday David or Burma gameplay
guys messing around with or he was
playing the opening in the snow what was
crazy is that he went on a hunting trip
in the snow and left the trail and then
he came back and his trail was still he
followed his chill be out at the camp
which i think is really dope yeah cuz
like I don't know you can turn off the
map it I don't know I think it's really
cool here's so yeah you have basically
components here so you need to know you
get your weapons cleaned which over time
your stats will kind of decrease so you
want to keep your weapons clean you can
do that here
components or like stat boosts some of
them not so much like rap is a lot of
rap I'll put on doesn't do much but like
you can get like a pistol barrel long a
lengthened and that will increase like
the accuracy I haven't done much of this
yet but it's pretty cool actually I'm
gonna take this off Oh Dee cases can you
leave the planet yes you can you can go
to the moon on a later mission there's
some Martians which is weird because you
always think Martians are on Mars but it
turns out in Red Dead the Martians are
on the moon right and the Wright
brothers help get you there yeah yeah
you meet the Wright brothers and they
fly you there it's pretty cool
it's weird he just puts on his bandana
and he can like withstand outer space
for some reason that like his oxygen
supply I guess so if you see here you
can do we're kidding guys so you can do
so much like metal colors here which is
pretty cool so I can go like that
can you Rob everyone well you can rob
pretty much anyone yeah
gang member I don't think you can rob a
gang member fellow gang member
the only there are a couple kids you see
in the game but I don't really think you
can interact with them apart from like
Jack you can say hi to them but you
can't you can't do anything mean to Jack
and I don't know why you would he's so
sweet and young so this is cool here you
can do carvings into your the wood here
yeah which is pretty dope Oh get that
mammoth mammoth or what is that urn oh
that's a bear I just saw the what is
that the thing looked like a tusk oh
yeah what is that I like this I like
this freaking yeah the Eagles pretty
cool badass get really drunk
what hives look at this can you rob gun
stores and steal guns you can rob gun
stores but you can't steal guns yeah
like and then you can also as mentioned
different ammo types so one of things to
know like also is that for hunting and
I've been doing this now because I
wasn't is you you see new animal you
hold r1 and you get to learn about the
animal and it'll tell you the best way
to kill it to give you the perfect
health which which is the best way to or
you know the highest return when you
sell it so like for instance a wolf I
found in the mountains it was like kill
it with a poisoned arrow for a perfect
pail or kill a kill a rat or something
with a varmint rifle Oliver Brown says
can anyone tell me if they were in the
swamp at any point no we haven't been to
the swamp yet however we couldn't go to
the swamp the swamp is really cool yeah
let's go let's do that let's take a
train and actually I'm just I'm close
enough huh yeah press I would go to log
r s which i think is zoom out a little
bit maybe you don't know here yeah right
there is yeah you're pretty close to
find some Gators someone did say they
want to see a gator so do that let's
let's get some Gator is it illegal to
drink and ride a horse now you can do it
right now
Rob can do it right now you can pop open
a
some Kentucky Bourbon or plug your gun
ooh
we didn't show this this is pretty dope
I think you guys like this let's check
this out oh yeah a little flair
when does the campaign go live uh it
depends on your time zone for us it's
9:00 p.m. or civic 12:00 a.m. Eastern so
there's also a doctor go there there was
one time where it happened to me where
and Lucy as well here in the office I'm
going pretty fast where you come across
guys like my arm arm I thought my horse
you bring him to a doctor to help him
out
and the doctor comes off this frickin
arm amputee and it's intense can I
remove comments I think you can hide all
the comments if you want on YouTube
I'm not sure though is the Matt bigger
than GTA's I don't know I think so it
seems bigger very hard to do that for
hard to compare yeah I'm sure someone
will like like with GTA's map inside of
this at some point it is very big though
I can tell you that like I was trying to
get from one side to the other and it
took probably while I died but like it
takes around probably like 30 minutes
unless you're really booking it but
since your horse's stamina and you can
wear them out if you just booked the
book it the whole way it probably takes
a while shoot the bow we did a little
bit before can Arthur 420 blaze it you
can smoke but not blaze it are we
haven't shown smoking yet no we haven't
let's uh let's show them how we smoke
oh I got that cigars comically big cigar
we've smoked so much our stamina core is
gone you know I actually I and I bought
it and then I went back a safe so uh see
ceej says even if it isn't it's much
more detailed than GTA 5 yeah the world
is incredibly detailed it is so deep the
vegetation man is outstanding necro says
can you activate your Quinn sign I wish
so a lot of people want to see some of
the areas in the map that are also in
the first game we go to the desert I
mean I haven't seen it yet and I'd be
cool I mean I think we should try okay
oh you see like this is an example of
just like a random house that I was like
there's no you can enter this but yeah
here we are
I hope no one Minds me taking all their
stuff a shotgun how am i doing okay be a
burglar did you steal some stuff yeah I
saw some jewelry some tonic Oh most to
the swamp oh oh [ __ ] what someone
someone it was a night shot you saw me
steal Gandalf to me and Dolph makes a
good point yes he says GTA v is scaled
for car and aircraft travel so it's full
of a more empty space that's a good
point this game in general you move
through the world much slower so that
means maybe the world isn't as big just
because it doesn't need to be but it's
also more detailed because you're moving
through the world slower and kind of
taking it into smaller details as
opposed to flying over it in a jet
aircraft as cool as that is
sorry I'm not playing very well we
should get to the swamp everyone I see
some Gators I just want to show this
guy's head and pop off oh it's trying to
dead I don't have any left
oh my god
there you go what guns do already have
well he's got the pump shotgun feed his
body to the Gators we should try that
can you try to try that I mean I gotta
be resourceful right not that bad of a
game airing that's how I feel says the
map is bigger so I want to play it on my
phone I don't that doesn't sound fun it
doesn't sound fun at all wait so this
game has two discs I don't know it's 90
gigs that's pretty big I don't know how
much typically PlayStation 4 discs hold
we should be able to find out tomorrow
though yeah you can blow heads off and
blow limbs off one time I like oh you we
were doing it you like put a dynamite
next to a guy and he incinerate him yes
it was gone
holy [ __ ] that man was obliterated yes
he was alright so there are a lot of
Gators swimming around in these parts
here gross he has oh we didn't show this
show what this is a big deal something
you couldn't do in legend zelda Oh crazy
doesn't matter she didn't you know he
come here Oh
sometimes it's so finicky come here okay
see the body we see the headless body on
your horse say like what cuz I have
blood on me dude I'm just a medial your
murderer no it's probably because
there's a freakin I just want to pet
this damn dog Hey look at that tail oh
he doesn't think you're a murderer who I
am you don't care about on or do you boy
you have a companion dog no but well
actually I think there's one that'll
hang around your camp eventually no is
this the real game yeah is about as real
as it is the game gets I'd say so the
horse really doesn't like I'll see Carl
or here really doesn't like Gators
oh crap we're trying to feed it to the
Gators right now we are frying our
wanted a wanted man wanted because I did
a big no-no I mean it's not that bad
right do it to chill baby oh oh my god
oh my god she's so far away because
that's the thing is like everywhere you
go there's a gator
can you talk your way out of a crime yes
you can
how are the supercars well they're great
like I said I flew under the moon the
other day so I think that counts is
feeding the Gator that was some
Gatorades something all right should we
try to get to the other side of the map
def Wow I my run-ins with Gators were
we're fine up until that point that was
a little surprising karma definitely
these comments are going crazy I'm
having trouble keeping up with them can
we play today you can play it 9 p.m.
Pacific
so yeah that's today Eastern I think
it's midnight oh my god can you go
bowling with Roman I wish I never
thought I'd miss bowling with Roman so
the way I see it is you want to go if
we're gonna get there you want to go as
far as far west as you can and then
travel down ok so let's go to strawberry
or we'll go to is Riggs yeah we'll go to
Riggs save time
Wow that Gator I think I was just
talking about a gear so there's a
station close by it looks like two that
we have that we know oh wait no you're
close to the Sun didn't you want you're
gonna have to pay your bounty though if
you want to take it but there there's a
post office right next to that one so
you should be okay yeah that's the
closest yeah
hey gamer spot hope you get more great
videos thank you yeah we got then tons
of stuff Kony there's tons of stuff
already there we did a recap of Red Dead
1 even if you're very familiar threat
dead 1 it's still very entertaining
Joey and Lucy did an excellent job on
that if you're really excited for Red
Dead I put out a video called the DNA of
Red Dead Redemption 2 and it's basically
how this game draws inspiration from old
rockstar games we have another video
coming tomorrow that should be quite
exciting as well as I think our
beginners guide went up today yeah we
have a beginner's guide you know which
obviously you if you you know want to
come back to that the other thing I
think we're gonna look into doing is
like a money guide which I personally
want to want to look at because I don't
know the first like 10 hours or so it's
kind of you kind of broke yeah there are
so many things you can immediately buy
but you don't have much money so it's
it's a good way of like kind of
refreshing like alright
these are the best ways to like make
money quick yeah I think I think my
biggest tip though is just to play the
story because yeah there are missions
where you get a lot where you get a lot
of money yeah and you can tell that it's
like it's kind of like trying to get you
from just getting the most expensive
things right away they want you to like
get to a certain point in a store and
that's when you get a nice chunk of
change but if you are having fun robbing
trains and robbing carriages and robbing
people you can totally make money that
way take two interactive stock is flying
that doesn't surprise me
does this game have cars no not good I
have to see I'm cart
it's got carts yeah you're gonna have to
pay her bounty I think before we can
that's fine
hit the road is Arthur Morgan a great
protagonist yes I think he's fantastic
yeah me too
I was worried too going in I thought he
seemed just kind of like generic like
angry cowboy but he's really I think
he's one of rockstars best characters as
well I think what's really cool is that
you know I feel like he fits the game
well in that he works as a character
that is both good and bad yes so
perfectly like just how he speaks it's
like I find very fascinating yeah
because it's it's so intentionally and
brilliantly like divisive of however
yeah like it's like yeah it's vague
exactly yeah that's cool can you swim
yes you can this game make you feel like
Gerald of Rivia no I don't know says
please save the live video yeah we'll
save this live video you have to run
because wow we've been at it for two
hours yeah we're still going I know I
still feel like there's a lot I want to
show yeah I agree
please rob a train that'd be awesome we
do in a rob a train I could Rob Rob this
train yeah let's do it you have so we is
did yeah there's gameplay it's on our
gameplay channel it's it's quite good
it's like a robbery that went off with
very few hitches which is tough to do
with train robberies because like if you
board the wrong car if you take too long
yeah if you rob the wrong like I once
robbed a cargo train which I couldn't
hold any people up here here's what I'll
do this will be the easiest way to do it
so I don't cuz I want a bounty yeah yeah
that's a good point 30 frames a second
it seems like that but it's pretty it's
it's pretty consistent also I know
people are gonna hate me for this but I
think in a cinematic game
I prefer 30 frames a second mmm that's
fair just because cinema is 24 frames
sometimes 30
and I and I think it adds like a film
quality especially for cut scenes maybe
during gameplay I totally get the
argument that you want 60 frames but
okay so I will show you guys
nice little skid there make sure to put
your bandana on you know it so yeah I've
done this a couple times and it took me
a while to understand how to
successfully rob a train because it's
actually oh crap I got on it quick
someone says cue play is a Native
American or a black character no you
cannot however I believe in online
you'll be able to customize your
character and you'll be able to pick
your race as well and probably I would
expect pick a female cowgirl yeah I'm
pretty sure they have said you can't
play as a cowgirl so sick so Wow he
already has forty percent complete in
two hours no no we've been playing for
the past week I think I'm at eighty
percent here gunshots peasant eyes can't
see but beyond thirty anyway okay
who is shooting oh we can show that this
is pretty you might have different save
files yes you can you can have different
save files autosave your auto saves will
overwrite between files but as long as
you hard save you'll be fine
are there lots of customization options
in the story like character
customization yeah there's a ton in
terms of weapons horse you can even
customize the heck out of your horse
which is pretty cool like you can give
like yeah for sure get like braided pink
Mane's which i think is a little too
much for me especially and how grounded
this game feels but if that's your thing
here's my big tip is that if you want to
rob a train go for the passenger car
first because the train will eventually
stop I love that animation so much you
know what also sucks if you do that and
then there's a freaking bridge there's a
bridge but where the bridge lining is
flush with the cart and I was like I got
on I was like oh she just nailed a
[ __ ] bridge Oh check this out can you
replay missions yes you can just like in
the first one
how much does robbing affect your honor
it definitely affects your honor but I
don't know if it is like I don't have a
significant effect by by head
nice here's what you want to do is you
want to get here first
someone says movies to frame blending
games do not 30 frames a second a game
looks worse than 25% with pre-rendered
cutscenes that I don't know my my big
thing was I remember the last of us had
a 60 frames per second on ps4 and I did
not like that at all because it looked
like 60 frames did not work well on
those cutscenes maybe that was how they
rendered them maybe you could be right
for sure but me personally I do like 30
frames a second when it comes to
cinematic games but you know a game like
Call of Duty Halo I cannot do 30 frames
a second can you steal horses totally
can so here here's the other thing you
want to do so you robbed the passengers
and then you go back here and I would
imagine there are some trains that have
like maybe bigger like stashes or saves
you want it you don't have like a
lockpick you have dynamite
I shouldn't even I shouldn't even talk
about friends for a second
someone says please acknowledge my
question I missed your question sorry
there's a lot going through here can you
do first person yes you can have you
beaten the game I have took me around 45
hours that's all I'll say
sometimes get drunk yes so this is drive
the Train have you seen this yet oh you
can drive it yeah
oh let's let's get out of here I know
you could do this it's pretty cool yeah
is there you've got Matic weapons not
that I've found except for like mini
guns that you find that you can like
mounted gun please let me run this guy
over please please please please please
please please please
[Music]
can you get different bandanas yes you
can
where's the online it'll be here in a
couple weeks so I'm underwater now you
can't is the map an island like GTA 5 no
the north is not an island and the East
I don't think is an island like it's not
no the map is not centered by water can
you ride this train into the it's slower
though yeah but they're not gonna be
able to get you the laws like we will
get you if you ride a train into it well
let's see if I'm even going the right
way
no dang you can turn this thing around
just pick it up
we're like back it up let's just start
back here
so that's Rodney trained pretty cool you
can get some good stuff wellthat
something we haven't talked about there
are like trinkets and talisman talisman
talismans cuz it just called trinkets or
what trinkets and talismans yeah yeah
geez what's the difference he says bro
you're dumb they had fully automatic
guns and Red Dead Redemption
yeah but Red Dead Redemption 1 took
place later than this game does and like
I said there are mounted guns they're
fully automatic and there are
semi-automatic guns like you can get a
semi-automatic shotgun pistol I don't
even get a semi-automatic rifle I don't
think so
Thursday remember though there's a
repeater shotgun yeah
there's a semi-automatic shotgun a
repeater shotgun and somehow two
semi-automatic pistols oh this is a
trapper so these guys will take health's
and stuff right anyways let's go to the
desert
can you shoot yourself now how many
revolvers I think I was like six six or
seven Oh reverse specifically I think
there's like four maybe and there's some
pistols as well that like aren't
considered revolvers at least in the
weapons stores there aren't like a lot
of weapons
I feel like Bishop Lemmon says this chat
goes by fast
yes that's I'm having trouble getting to
all these questions if your horse dies
do you lose stuff I don't think so I
don't know though um I've been had a
horse die on me well if there have been
times where I've been robbed or died oh
and all you can jump off you can go off
a cliff with your horse like don't do it
don't do it let's we got to be focused
we gotta get low back my say no we got
to be focused we got to the South people
really want to see respect respect the
south no no I want to see the south I
haven't seen it yet please show tall
trees for a nostalgic purpose we'll
probably go through tall trees yeah
we're kind of getting into more of like
the if you compare anything to like kind
of like Northwest USA original one well
just like trees forests like redwoods
Pacific Northwest yes uh oh my gosh what
do you get with the ultimate edition I
think you get the map right you get that
fabric map and then you get a bunch of
DLC stuff any info on online what it's
about not really
I think IGN did an interview a while
back that kind of talked a little bit
about it but it's a pretty vague I think
what we know is I mean we connect we can
assume it's gonna be similar to GTA
online it sounds like it'll be a slower
paced GTA online but the whole map is
only abstract it don't get Rob Rob Stan
he said help it's okay Stan of course no
no we can't do this row he wants a ride
screw that you're on you're on sorry bud
how are you guys playing so early
Rockstar providers review codes earlier
for review
and to create content around the game so
we're ready to hopefully help you guys
out when the game launches and answer
all your questions is John Marsten's
ranch still there I mean you can go
there I don't know if it's there or not
I mean it's probably not his like yeah
like you probably wouldn't have it cuz
he's in this gang considering how the
map is features hope has to be there but
I don't know I don't know it's there can
you build a house anywhere on the map
you can't build a house period just so
you know this town's cool he's like a
mountain hillbilly town does this look
better on xbox one extra ps4 Pro it will
piss or Xbox one X's native 4k so
probably Xbox 1x but the difference is
probably pretty small is there a casino
in Red Dead - no but there are a bunch
of you can bet there's a lot of ways you
can bet cool I'm excited I haven't seen
any like I've gone past here well we'll
see if we'll get past here Oh have you
killed any legendary animals and were
they a challenge I've killed three and
not really I've killed one yeah not
really
they're not like legendary in terms of
like I think assassin's creed had like a
mythical where they were like really
tough this like if you're smart you can
do it have you done one associated with
a legendary cougar in a cave no I have
not that sounds pretty [ __ ] it was so
dope and it was extremely difficult
because the Cougar kept coming out in
the dark you hey the thing was you had
to have your lantern because was pitch
black it was pretty scary and the Cougar
the Cougar would one-hit kill you
uh kind of like that croc Alex lesson
says can you shout me out alright as
shout out to Alex lessons thanks for
stopping by and watching her like I said
if you have any questions drop them in
the chat before you ask questions you
can smoke you can swim and part of the
Red Dead one map is in this game as well
and I don't know what are some of the
big questions we've been getting you can
only sit in certain areas you can only
sit in certain areas what's here are
they're River boots boots are there
river boats you can board and Rob there
are river boats there are boats they dug
rowing boats I've done I think I I
imagine you could probably rob some of
them the docked ones is a weird question
is there nudity I don't think so I
haven't seen any nudity I ran over a
rabbit if you don't eat will it affect
you yes Arthur gets skinny it won't
really hurt your health however you'll I
think like people do like 5% more damage
if you're underweight to you oh my gosh
there are so many questions I can't keep
up could you go to the desert please
that's where we're headed can you go to
jail I don't think so you can surrender
like you can in previous GTA games I
mean you could do that right that you
just basically up here in the state side
yeah I like phase 2 black you lose some
money
how are the pre-order bonuses don't know
I don't think we have them on here
get him fat it would take a long time
for us do that can you jump and fall
like in GTA yeah you can you should we
for good measure run into a tree or
something I feel so bad with my horse
like it kind of hurts like I said like I
said let's not get sidetracked this is
all new
is there difficulty settings No
oh my gosh there are so many are there
brothels no but you can find ladies of
the night at saloons you can't do much
more than just chatting with them that's
a bear does the game run smoothly
on-base ps4 I don't know I didn't play
it on base ps4 if you don't eat will it
affect you affect you yeah you'll take a
little bit more damage
can you see horse testicles yes but this
is a few mill horse you can't see it on
this one that's another question people
I'm asking phone app news I think it's
bull my god night what happened freaking
cougar man hole oh my god my heart just
skipped because that's happened before
and it didn't go that well
[Music]
can you ride horses in this game nope no
horse riding in this game this is the og
West world yeah but it's got a much
better story than West world so it's a
burn does this game contain violence
nope it's rated E for Everyone
so that was a poor help because I shy
with a shotgun I should have killed it
with whatever it would have recommended
where's my damn horse
probably [ __ ] out of here
[Music]
what new animals are there to kill
honestly I couldn't list them all right
now they're I think like 150 animals I
think it says in the compendium there's
a ridiculous amount of animals that vary
depending on where you are in the map
finding them all would be take a long
time so here's the camp I'm gonna do
this I have entered legendary animal
territory Rob don't get distracted I'm
going we got to show what the people
want
I know I know no I'm just doing this
because my cores are low and they're not
on to show some of this cooking so
what's cool is like you can pick up like
herbs and stuff and they'll help bill
add buffs so here for instance if I put
mint on this it was fully restores all
chords and a gold health core for a day
so that's like extra like protection
right is basically what that is and then
oregano affects stamina and time a text
I'm Rockstar editor return it does not
least not yet
hopefully they added at some point but
there's a really cool cinematic camera
and you can take photos there's a photo
mode it's very in world though like you
have a camera so you can't like pause
the game and like pan the camera way out
which is kind of a bummer considering
how beautiful this game is but you know
they love their realism so the other
thing you can do here is craft other
items so like revolver split points and
stuff which is pretty cool can I give my
wife's four-year-old son
scheme I wouldn't recommend it it's
pretty gruesome
yeah we're not can you buy horses yes
you can buy horses they're expensive
well some of them are expensive does
your hair grow yes does can you get
arrested yes you can can you go in the
first person yes you can are there color
blind settings there are however I don't
know how good they are because I know a
lot of games don't do a very good job
with those settings I couldn't tell you
if this does does it okay or not
what's the weather like it ranges from
all sorts of things
rainy thunderstorms fog cloudy sunny
beautiful foggy if Arthur gets shot will
there be blood yep they'll be blood home
covered in blood
I know my question I'm super impressed
do you know if there's any anything is
there a downside to not tearing down
your camp I don't know my guess was that
if you try to set up your camp it would
be like if you try this up your camp
somewhere else be like your campus
already SEP some roast you can't do this
that would be my guest but I don't know
also it's kind of cold 31 degrees should
I put on my winter coat no okay
most valuable animal I'm not sure bite
they're a bison I think I feel like
those are pretty valuable huh no I
killed one and sold the pelt for $2 and
I really know it's really cool advice
and though is like they're so freaking
big that you have to skin them because
you can't put it on your horse and uh
one cool tip is on bigger animals if you
last home and get close you just let
their throat for an instant clean kill
that's what ed was saying do you go to
prison if you get arrested it's not like
the Elder Scrolls games or you're
actually like in a prison I think you
just you said you just appear right
outside right yeah yeah oh [ __ ]
and yo can you take MPC leg off with a
shot yeah I think if you get a shotgun
in the legs or if you like throw some
dynamite we saw that guy's leg and yeah
England's can get dismembered and like
we haven't done in here but you can put
a dynamite next to a guy and he will pop
and we'll be incinerated
this game is is this xbox one no this is
ps4 Pro that we are playing on yes there
are 18 breeds of horses that sounds
about right there are a lot of breeds of
horses can you play an instrument no
Robert can't get distracted
in the middle of the road
Robert don't do it I just want saying
you don't do it I just won't say
anything
someone's giving away read please don't
yeah but don't don't do that on our
stream please you will get banned
yeah it's messed up alright I'm not
really sure where I'm going I'm going
backwards
so I know no start going down now like
don't follow the road cross the river
yeah don't follow the road because
usually there's law can you play with
John Marston yeah he's or he's arounds I
mean you can't be John Marston because
this is Arthur's story but you can like
hang out with them co-op on day one
there's no co-op in the story mode I
think yeah I mean I guess they'll be
co-op in multiplayer is there a desert
level we're gonna try and see what we
get there are you you feel confident we
can know okay I think we're gonna get
shot but let's see if I let's see if I
can get there we'll see I think if we
don't take the road we have a better
shot someone wants to know hey someone's
asking King you smoked in this game no
it's a bummer it's like probably one
thing psyche you could totally soaked
smoke science bigger than yeah look at
that look at that
are there more stars in the sky than and
read them read Redemption 1 I think so
the night sky looks pretty dang pretty
yeah we are really going off-road here
yeah
someone says Tupac dies at the end of
this game oh yeah sorry I spoiled it and
the notorious b.i.g survives can you
breed horses now what is the FPS I think
30 solid 30 don't say 30 there's so many
questions I've answered all these many
times to just come back to them they
keep coming oh my God look at that chat
I know I mean I'm gonna take a little
break from the chat just for a second
and taking the sites I feel like I
haven't looked at the game in a long
time
dang came by horse stables no he can't I
just did it I looked at the chat are you
playing with a match I don't know will
this game affect my midterms yes
probably probably I would wait until
after your midterms before you really
dive into this oh I was in this I was in
this snowy mountains on my horse and
like I had like a panic attack we like
slid down probably like 30 yards my
horse was very freaked out
whoa Oh see you like right there whoa
sorry it's like snowboarding you might
have to you might have to Huff it on
foot a little bit you know I might but I
also am a drink in like I don't know if
I turn around and I do this I think you
can look at you you're so close I think
I think you can do it I mean I wonder if
this is the edge of the map maybe trying
foot cuz so when I went to this the
mountains a like this is how this is
what happened and like wouldn't let me
well then go that way and see cuz that
it's not as steep maybe you could just
kind of like edge around it can you do
jujitsu no man all right well then maybe
get a little closer to the road look at
look at the mini-map see that like fat
yeah get closer to the road then like
you know like that
yeah maybe try try like around there or
like mark mark this part of the road
right here and try to get me there I
mean it's yeah it's telling you to go
that way I think it might just be too
steep like I would just try other areas
answer why country around here it's like
a right you go the other way
edge of the map guys edge of the map
it's not though you're looking at the
map can you do poor sis not that I know
can you commit suicide oh my gosh
someone asked how long it take you to
beat the game around 45 hours I would
say and I didn't do a lot of side stuff
if you get this I highly recommend doing
the side stuff I'm kind of afraid I'm
gonna kill my horse doing something like
all right can you have a pet dog no but
there is a dog that kind of hangs around
the camp at some point which is kind of
cool you might have to like you might
just have to go down and like follow the
like cute fly a plane you go only
Firefly plane in that story mission
where you go to the moon oh no you're
fine you're fine you're fine you're fine
that's not a far drop you can make it
okay
okay see oh oh we're good baby if you
kill your horse do you need to buy
another one yeah yeah that's why it's
really tense can you pick up bodies like
an Hitman or metal gear yes you can
how much would you get bounties turned
in can you do the side missions after
you beat the main story some of them you
can others you cannot so that's why I
think it's worth it take your time just
go I would say sorry I'm no you're good
I'm kind of I needed that direction
oh is that a beaver I need that shock on
it this is kind of difficult when you
when you get like oh there's that hot
swimming gameplay to forever oh yeah
swimming is just pushing it into Shore
yeah there's no other way to do it I got
it's it's this is actually working out
to be tricky though so what one of the
reasons why I wanted this beaver is
because it's it's um I have a beaver
rabbit and a deer I can make my satchel
that I carry better so yeah come here
Karl or that's a big beaver can you swim
we just did it it's probably catching up
on chat you'll see it soon
here
oh so if you skin an animal it
automatically gives you the meat well
gives you the info it look like the
compendium oh yeah
opposed to like studying it over do you
need a feeder water your horse you don't
need to but you probably should I gotta
feed the horse right now okay oh [ __ ] do
my horse you not go any further
no again it's just I'm really stressing
this horse out
beat it are there children in this game
yes there are can you rob banks in free
roam I haven't been able to maybe I'm
just doing it wrong though seem Bigfoot
no but I hope he's in here alright
all right this is manageable now yeah
where are we it seems like we're making
progress we're about to get we're
heading towards the dam and then maybe
we can just stick to the river yeah like
a part of me wants to find a boat you
know and then the cops wouldn't the
copies really can get oh I think the
boat you'll be well we'll see how many
weapons can you hold your horse can hold
all your weapons ha ha your horse can
hold all your weapons but Arthur can
only hold two rifles and two pistols if
you're away from yours can you get high
I mean you can do drugs
there's the dam you might have to swim
across your horse can swim oh they want
to see you drag somewhere the last I
seen a couple question oh sure I can
check come on baby what's going on here
come on there you go there you go that's
all you needed just need to angle a
little bit differently
Oh someone that we did not show this
I'll show it first person Aiden
aim-down-sights we could do that
I guess there isn't he was a smoker
maybe tried different
I didn't think there was I thought there
was
I don't think I have a scope on this one
what kind of hairstyles are there
there's a good amount so there's an to
quacky though so there's no
aim-down-sights
there's just this how do you hide chat I
think you could do it but I don't know
how how can you romance the horse
I'm confirmed oh all right
let's check the map again see where we
are cuz we were I think we're about to
get into wanted territory where uh all
right
mark mark somewhere lower down the map
I'd say yeah maybe over there keep us
like right on the edge let's uh cuz I'm
gonna have to be line in or what like
they're gonna come after me yeah but
like when I tried to do this it wasn't
even matter of coming after you it was
just you just get shot every direction
and died but I also went in close to
black water and black water is like
apparently on high alert I'm gonna put a
health buff on
see what happens we're in it boys yeah
we might be good just because we're like
so far away from Blackwater yeah I hope
we are be cool they're like hope so so
far so good
so if we do make it there one thing I
will say it's not spoilery oh [ __ ] oh
you got nowhere to go
this was a dead end no no my watch Oh
turn it again well I'm off there I'm off
their radar come on baby come on baby I
love you so much let's go Carlo
you might just have to go back through
them let me try it again
that looks good I got up there well they
left so maybe this is bet and then maybe
this is good can you enter every house
in the map and Robin no but there are a
good amount of houses that you can enter
oh my god chill out baby chill right
there
whenever my to read that one
so should go here right yeah I pass him
yeah whip around all right go here we go
yep we're in tall trees does someone
want to see tall trees holy [ __ ]
it's so saying like you get there and
it's just like you got to get past that
first wave so fast we're gonna be able
to do it like that was promising at
least like how you got away from him
yeah right
let's see where I am oh we're right on
the border well we're not too far away
can you die in the snow do you mean like
freeze to death no you can't
can you get a man bun please don't judge
me no I don't think so can you answer my
question this chats going crazy there's
a lot of questions you're gonna have to
answer ask it again and I'll see what I
can do
but if it's offensive I won't yeah you
can change outfits I can do it right
here all right you ready to book it yep
Oh am I good like good we're all right
so you're gonna hang an immediate left
or this
I still want to come right in front of
me you know yeah they're in front of me
then that's that's the bomber I wanted
behind me what's that a cougar to my
left go nope Oh looks like they spawn in
a bad spot though I think you're good I
think you're good oh I think I think
we're golden
oh [ __ ] no no oh no oh no all right
check map see which way you probably
don't keep going straight I imagine
right straight on me straight right yeah
keep going straight or right actually or
left sorry that might be better cuz
you'll cut through the Great Plains yeah
I do left yeah yeah okay so then what
like here left and then just left them
down because I don't want to go too
close to Blackwater
no okay just like that
kind of getting close to those guys but
we're okay
oh so this is pretty cool we're seeing
some redwoods now yeah tall trees I
think tall trees end or have you already
ran someone over the train no we got
close to it though we're good I just
hope they don't keep coming that's cool
house there
put your dog on a leash we're now where
let's keep going south right yep Oh does
it look like it end it ends there maybe
I don't know The Wanted zone we'll see
it might because technically new Austin
is a different state so maybe if you get
past the new Elizabeth your home or uh
West Elizabeth you're home free can you
have more than one mount yeah you can
have four horses oh oh there's more
lawmen oh crap dude they're right on the
road too you could go all the way around
or down or this way yes I'm saying you
could go oh you meant this way I was
thinking the over here but yeah this
okay let's do that damn those guys are
off road to fast travel option there are
ways to fast travel you can either take
a carriage a train or later you'll
unlock a map at camp that allows you to
fast travel the settlements however you
can only fast travel to them you can't
travel back to camp
ooh they are hot on your trail crap
which I keep going this way
yeah I'd keep going this way or maybe
you could maybe instead of yeah
they can smell me
can you carry a flat no but you can
carry a lot of liquor they are freaking
me out
damn we got here's some desert plains
we're close to Plains sure one thing I
will say yeah we're all some Aries in
the first game oh god whom I don't have
yeah yeah so I'm saying it's tough once
you get to the plains they are there
like yeah I think it's like wide open
and it's open range and they can cut
across it's not going to work out
alright well we tried it's right it's
clearly not letting us that's what I was
saying it's pretty tough and it looks
like it does continue down into like a
look you can see a little bit of red
down there too oh you're right
like even if I get past it's just a hole
that's wide open desert so uh well
should we do anything else that's pretty
good should we call it it's up to you
what if we do one last thing
alright and then we'll call it sounds
good what is there to do we have not
shown yet or you guys want to see we go
to Valentine and do another bar fight I
feel like we got like a really good bar
fighting never got a really good bar
fight and I think we also never did the
hotel and show debating is like oh yeah
when we do those two things we'll call
it we can take a bath and then we can
fight immediately after yeah fight okay
let's do that
do a bank robbery
we can try a bank robbery but I don't
know how to like maybe maybe we can put
some dynamite on the door maybe that'll
work is there bait there's a bank in
Valentine there's a bank in Valentine
let's go to Martin's future we can't we
tried we tried it's the game clearly
prevents us yeah like it's unlike to be
honest I think this is better like even
though it's not really a spoiler like
people already know you can go there
there's like a really cool feeling going
there on your own and like seeing that
and like revisiting a lot of those
places at least I thought it was one of
my favorite moments I think in the game
was just returning back to those places
and seeing how they've how different
they are how technology how the
technology today is like kind of shaped
them and made them look better like do
you member andread did one where you
first hit that Ridge and you just see
the planes like sprawling sure yeah and
this it is like breathtaking yeah that's
cool yeah I'm sure they have it all
figured out my scale is a hundred times
like bigger than it wasn't that first
scale it's huge now sure it's like
fairly linear right in a good way as far
as like how they approach you look at
this dog oh sorry there's no bank in the
strawberry there's a bank in Valentine
can you guys pay off the bounty I guess
we could he's getting all muddy
oh let's go
[Music]
can you do a wield pistols and revolvers
yes you can yes you can can you get
prostitutes like fallout you can only
get robot prostitute so I can Fallout
New Vegas in this game no actual people
so that might be disappointing you can
get prostitutes in Fallout New Vegas
yeah you can get robot ones and they
just like talk to you it's pretty funny
why did I go here I thought there's
gonna be a train but there's not how big
is the map relative to GTA 5 I can't
tell you off the top of my head someone
in the chat said it's bigger it feels
bigger but I think part of that might
just be because it's slower paced like
I'm riding a horse instead of driving a
car flying a plane mm-hmm
but I'm sure very soon someone will do a
map comparison I will say this map is
far more detailed than GTA 5 which is
saying a lot because you tafe I've had a
pretty detailed map oh this guy
recognizes me I guess so I actually
don't remember this guy but I helped him
out a while ago and he oh just a minor
please do not pimp your own channel
giveaways the chats going fast but if I
see it I will time you guys out so
are there lots of hairstyles not as much
as GTA but there's quite a few can
Arthur eat his hat you found any Easter
eggs yes
so don't to spoil anything though
there's some big Easter eggs that are
very very good are you an Xbox no this
is ps4 Pro GTA 5 is huge yeah but it
felt empty Red Dead Redemption didn't
have that problem hope part two doesn't
either I don't think so I think like
there isn't yeah Red Dead Redemption
feels like there's always something
happening when you're riding around like
they'll be some I mean it's not too bad
but every now and then you'll see
someone like I don't know trapped in a
bear trap or some sort of interaction
you can do that kind of breaks up the
pace of these along travel times can
horses attached to coaches be detached
from you yes they can
okay recap for the closing of the stream
take a bath bar fight rob a bank
alright I'll punch someone L just run
right into the bank and see if I can rob
it
you gotta do more fighting is that fair
do you regain arrows after killing
something
yes killing it yeah if you walk over it
yeah it just automatically oh wait come
on we got a question can you smoke you
could show that off yeah game good
graphics yeah it's got some really good
graphics
how long does a loading take when you
first start up it doesn't take as long
as GTA 5 no it doesn't it's quite quick
yeah even with um but it takes longer
when you start up and if you die in
reload yeah
loading saves isn't too bad either I
would say but this is on a pro I don't
know how it is on just for that's a good
point
I imagine the ps4 also probably runs
cannot loud because my game will run
pretty loud with spider-man and I have
to imagine this game is probably a bit
more taxing on the console and there's
the bank
what's going on with framerate it's run
pretty smooth for us it might be this
might be your stream you buy houses now
can you get drunk before the bar fight I
don't know should we have a couple uh so
that yeah I can have a couple drinks so
this this is pretty cool so this is one
of houses that like you start off and it
like it's practically just a bare
minimum frame so it's slowly being built
over time which is neat actually I wanna
I want to show that if you see these
guys like hammering they're like they're
like actually putting boards and they
really are yeah it's like really cool
that saw from no you can't go prone you
can try the balcony up the street a lot
of times like you'll see them passing up
wood and Nate no no the other way it may
be built though by now for you the
balcony
I hear construction I don't know where
it is no he probably doesn't like me
because I was an [ __ ] this hound this
first town I mean it doesn't really like
you
Beth now there I need a bath quick can
you mind Bitcoin at Bitcoin mines yep
they're only on the moon though so can
you shoot through objects yeah some of
them so I don't know if they shoot
through but you can like destroy cover
so eventually you can shoot through
objects oh yeah what are the controls
like for sprinting they're pretty much
the same as GTA 5 however I think you
can turn off the tap X thing if you
don't like that I personally do but and
you carry a blast no you can carry a ton
of alcohol though first person yep it's
here oh hello can you bathe it your camp
I don't think so
she like insinuates that she could like
take it to the next level but Arthur
isn't into it you can also tell her you
don't want any small chips all talk
either this dialogues always yeah he'll
talk about his dog at some point I feel
like you did anything to say about the
bandana
I mean if use properly you won't get a
bounty attached to Arthur Morgan so you
can commit crimes they'll all still come
after you but they won't be able to pin
it on you that's all I have to say about
it I forget to use it a lot and I get in
trouble may I be stuck flouted mcfarland
ranch
you buy property now don't you can don't
I haven't done it but apparently you can
donate to one of the like another house
nearby that's being built I feel like
yeah and and son the knee there's a
building you can donate handle me can
you ride a shrimp no can you ride a
shrimp these two guys should shut up I
don't hear they're disgusting voices no
fun that's harsh we're trying to answer
all you guys questions he seems to be in
the minority because of how many
questions are how good is the melee
system I think it's the best melee
system in a rockstar game except for
maybe like I didn't play the Warriors
but that game is all about melee systems
maybe that's better yeah you have
options you have like block you have
like kind of like what you call a like I
think it's called struggle you can grab
them and like yeah um a lot of bully I
think like it's it's a little tighter
than GTA 5's and bully has a little bit
more options although not as many combos
because this game isn't my god it's this
so this is the guy I stole his hat he
doesn't have it anymore
[Music]
can you put his hat on oh no it's on
your horse
I'm totally dirty I hope I'll just shoot
and kill you if you've done enough bad
someone else was saying oh sorry
hey open your eyes hey mister open guys
what I was gonna say was the that guy
that like mountain man I'm sorry damn
that was in your horse oh is it not no
your horses down the street you let you
go though yeah he did
damn my bad
that's pretty clenched someone please oh
we're about to can you go to new Austin
yes you can oh I can see why he was
wearing a hat
yeah well hat anymore
it's really cool videos I know right and
the other thing too is that he he sounds
a lot like Trevor that's really cool
that's like oh man that's like so
awesome chills that's so cool one look
how's the stealth it's much better than
GTA five Scalf it's hard though still
this tough [ __ ]
that's so awesome oh oh first person oh
[ __ ] I really don't like first person
it's really hard
this guy is such a tank
the sound effects room yeah they are
guys my thrown through the window yeah
what's up my hat
order up bartenders are there any two
NPCs that are the same I haven't noticed
any say oh I'd imagine you'd probably
come across some maybe in like the big
city
it wouldn't be surprised if there's some
that are similar but I also wouldn't be
surprised if there are none that are the
same just cuz it's Rockstar but III
don't know but I guess that says a lot
to the fact that I don't remember or I
can't speak to that alright make sure
put your bandana on before things go
down mm-hmm also there's always a guard
in there just you know no not that I
know
Franklin to see in the game yeah he's on
the moon can you crouch Q explain self
yes you can't crouch where's my horse
doing all right
sticking his butt at you I name any
weapons you can't crouch and it's pretty
much as you'd expect like there's no
there's no like all that Ubisoft sort of
stuff that they do like where time slows
down or like there's the little like
detection bar it's just kind of if
someone sees you they'll call you out
one thing I did notice is that if you
kill someone like mid-conversation then
they'll figure you out do you think you
can own a dog now you can't own a dog
from what I've played so far oh here we
go we've got passive displace
LOL the hat here we go and Joe Dixon
says great job guys thank you so you
have a cop to the left right away well
see he won't open it as a morning if
like dynamite can do it
this reminds me of inglorious basterds
that you know I'm talking about the song
I meant all you totally can ignite it I
try to ignite
weird however that worked out oh you
shut your ona that was in your horse I
hope it wasn't [ __ ] fire oh my god all
right see if the door is open I'm not
playing very well damn it didn't know
maybe try the other door there's another
door to the right
guys
there are no difficulties in this game
can you name your horse yet you can name
all Oh was that it
yeah there we go you're on dude damn so
now it doesn't look like it would taking
only rob banks during story missions
that's crap yeah I can't even like talk
to him
oh wow well maybe not this Bank alright
let's go pay the bounty now alright I
think that was uh I think that's gonna
be yeah a spot to end it I'd say
dynamite yeah what I've been waiting for
yeah I'm probably gonna want to go back
and save choice go as long as I can see
what happens I mean there's a you might
as well yeah
don't use any health stuff though no
more health okay no more health stuff
hey how'd you guys get the game so
really a rockstar provided us with early
copies in order to cut the review do
some do some guide content etc etc and
all guys's questions oh look a witness
cata saw me you are you are a terror
yeah I'm gonna want to go back like
throw through the bar window maybe see
if that works that'd be pretty cool well
you've got company this is pretty cool
even though I never played a game like
this I know oh there he goes
hello oppas is that guy's gone
maybe he'll incinerate
it's like night and day
doing combat outdoors here as compared
to like in that tight little tight
little Bank Peter's saying Jesus boys
what this town duty they didn't let us
get into the safe so now they're gonna
see already oh we didn't do a lasso on
the guy let's try that
do that do it there's someone here maybe
I'll go talk to him
does the game seem hard no it's not too
hard they're like when you get ambushed
sometimes I found myself dying just cuz
I wasn't ready but up for the most part
it's not too tough
I don't have my horse
I got tried other ammo types of news
you guys mean business
is the graphical actually like this I
mean yeah this is a pro ps4 pro so I
imagine I look better on Xbox one X and
it'll look of it with regular ps4 and
Xbox the stamina and health increases
you progress as you progress yeah as you
run more and stuff your stamina
increases but not and as you eat these
stuff I just told you not to use help I
know I just like I just like I got such
a good rhythm going on here
fire oh well look a fence break off
that's cool
who's saying 50 gig update on first day
I don't think there was one that we have
to count along but I guess it's not
first day yeah I don't think it's I
think it's like three gigs so stuff date
that no we had to do whole your bounty
is uh getting pretty high much better
graphics from GTA SA so this is like the
first game Rockstar is made with this
tech though like GTA 5 while it came to
Xbox one and ps4 that was still based
off last gem tech and it definitely
shows this is one of the prettiest games
I've ever seen
yeah least open-world wives yeah I agree
like the vegetation in this game is like
really yeah that was bad
alright no more health lasts and if you
where the masses honor go down no it
just prevents people from recognizing
you yeah laughter yeah it's harder for
your bounty to go up but I think at this
point
where is West Elizabeth in real life
doesn't exist in real life
let's just get drunk little preoccupied
right now but I could I think I could
probably down one no I'm out you can
smoke I can smoke one last smoke through
the bandana we got them now pretty cool
but the slow-mo killcams will get old
I don't think so they didn't turn them
off then oh and you can turn them off
but no you can turn yeah and that's all
she wrote and there we are
well that was quite the stream we went
for what almost three hours there
hopefully we answered your question I
know I answered a lot of questions you
did it as well
saw a ton of the game no spoilers but
yeah thank you all for stopping by and
make sure to check out all the videos we
have we have some cool gameplay some
funny gameplay we have like some really
good Red Dead videos including a tips
video that I highly recommend watching
if you plan on getting this game and
we'll have a rad video tomorrow Friday
yeah that's part of our show called
quick-draw which is basically a show all
about Red Dead Redemption too if you're
like me and you can't get enough it is
the perfect place to go I think that's
all I have to plug I'm good that was
that's everything I could think of yeah
yeah thank you guys so much that was and
dude props to you you uh you were
answering lots of questions your
questions I just one more time one more
time yes you can't smoke in this game
you're gonna do it for him I mean you've
got like 40 cigarettes 11 cigarettes
left I'm amazed we saw cigarettes left
all right
all right well now I know peace y'all
peace y'all but great rest of the week
and happy red dad day